zeke what's the american dream all about
for you
wow that's a great question um
i feel the american dream is doing what
you
love to do um i feel that it's not
actually necessarily a constant pursuit
but the idea of being happy um
thankfully i am pursuing my happiness
and
um you know i live my life that way uh
it's been a challenge to get to this
point but i gotta say like the american
dream to me is like literally striving
for something
but then achieving and then sharing that
with others
has the concept of the american dream
changed for you over time
absolutely yeah it changed um
as i was younger all i wanted to do was
be rich
um i have a very different um upbringing
um where my family started amusement
park
i literally was raised in amusement park
uh we would i would
i was the closest one to my grandfather
who helped build the park with his two
hands
and so we go around and do safety checks
and yadda yadda yadda and so i was in
the bowels of the of the
of the amusement park um and so but the
interesting thing about that was was you
saw these people having a great time
and enjoying themselves where we had to
work it
you know so there's this big disconnect
we provided the the enjoyment for other
people but we didn't participate in it
um and so it was it was um so
not being able to just be
always made me strive for something more
and so i thought it was going to be with
wealth
i literally wanted to my original
thought was going to be on wall street
uh and you know and and being a broker
or an analyst or whatever
and uh i got my my taste of that um and
um i hated it i literally walked out one
day i was making a lot of money and i
walked out because that wasn't life for
me
so when i was younger i thought chasing
the american dream was a matter of
chasing wealth but now i find
the american dreams actually chasing
happiness
and having um and sharing that's a big
thing
so when you were at that wall street job
and whether you were sitting in a
cubicle or
in front of a computer wherever on the
180th floor or wherever
yeah did did did you have filmmaking in
your mind
or at all nothing like that no no no i
um it was funny because
i walked out before i ever thought i was
gonna be a filmmaker um and so
um with my entertainment background of
the
park my finance background uh a buddy of
mine that was going to nyu film school
thought i'd make an excellent producer
and i knew nothing about producing film
whatsoever and so i started
to read as much as i could i fell in
love with it and
i decided that's what i was going to do
when i uh tucked my way into getting
accepted to syracuse grad school
and after my first semester my
professors like what the hell are you
doing going to school and i was like uh
i want to be a filmmaker she's like no
go do it why spend 27 thousand dollars
going to school
when you can make your first film for
that so i moved back
home refinanced the only asset that i
had which is a black jeep wrangler
got twelve thousand dollars for it and i
started my phone company and i've been
making movies ever since
and home is announced on pa and i moved
i moved back home
um you know like all my buddies were
going to new york or la
uh and some didn't land at that even at
that time but i decided i want to move
back home because
my family literally helped build the
area and because of the billy joel song
everybody outside the area
thought it was a poor depressed town and
i knew otherwise
and so i literally moved home to make a
difference to you know share with the
world what the
lehigh valley was like and that's kind
of like why i
i've been on this 20-year mission of
doing that and i haven't acquiesced
whatsoever it's been a struggle it's
been
a really really hard time doing what i'm
doing but we've had two films at
sundance we've premiered at the london
film
we've i've had success thank god but it
came with
with extraordinary amount of hard work
if you don't mind me asking did you
leave this job before
any market crash this analyst job or
whatever this is back in the early 90s
oh i see so things were going well oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i was actually analyzing
entertainment stocks on the tax sector
so it was my job to figure out where
studios had their money
because at that time all the deals are
back end and so like for instance people
don't realize that forrest gump never
made money
do we believe that but all the deals are
back end so the producers in the studio
would just you know put um put money
behind
you know basically lose money they would
hide they'd hide money
and so they never had to pay the
back-end deals
and so it was a big problem and
everything else and since then
hollywood's fixed it
but it's just a matter of um like that's
kind of like what i did was try to
figure out
what people were really making so you
left when the going was good so to speak
oh absolutely yeah
yeah yeah i think my mother still is
upset about it
because i would have been set quite
honestly you know instead of struggling
for 20 years i would have been
financially completely stable my entire
life when you looked around were there
other co-workers that
seemed satisfied with their jobs well
they would brag about making 30 000
that week and i looked at them and i
said you know my sister doesn't even
make that
an entire year it's a matter of getting
perspective and the next day i finally
walked out
so do you still keep in touch with any
of them do they say hey how's that movie
thing going no
no no no because it's like it's a
completely different world
you know um you know it's funny because
in my when i was younger i was a lot
more conservative than i am now
um and generally it's funny because i
know a lot of people at switches
um but you know like i was uh you know
sorry to change republicans
yeah my high school and everything else
and and i started to study religion and
that's actually what made me actually
become a little bit more liberal
uh and so forth so just is kind of like
it change it changed me
for going more liberal where if people
started studying religion they end up
becoming more conservative
um so i don't know that's how it worked
for me you were like alex p keaton of
family ties
yeah pretty much pretty much i mean it's
funny because when i was younger
uh see you know it might sound like i
had a silver spoon lodged up my derriere
having a family had amusement park but
it was completely you know
opposite of that um my family was
actually pretty poor
my mom went to uh decided to go to
seminary when i was in uh
uh elementary school and so we literally
worked to get my mom to school where
you know clean real estate office at
night my dad was in and out of work all
the time
um and so we literally like our
allowance is what we could save in
coupons
you know so i learned how to be very
frugal very young and
even though like my my rest of my family
was living
a very large life we were worried
day-to-day
and that always had a sensibility to me
too but the funny thing the reason i
bring that up is when i was a teenager i
was a hardcore punker
you know i used to go to all these shows
in new york and stuff i used to tag with
a bunch of people in new york and bronx
and so forth
and the reason that i was a punker is
because i couldn't afford what my peers
were wearing
so i go to thrift stores so i had to
separate myself i had to be different
you know and it's it's sad if you think
about it that way but it was kind of
like my defense mechanism
and and that's kind of like why you know
that was but as i grew a little bit
older
i then became a bit more conservative
and then the
alex p keating kind of garb started to
uh
to uh rear its head
being at the amusement park watching
your grandfather work can you talk about
how that shaped your business background
and then share some of the early lessons
you learned if you think about it this
way at any museum park
you have an amusement right you have
either it's a ride or it's entertainment
and around that you have some sort of
you have three different profit centers
generally you have merchandise games of
chance
food and so early on i learned
this concept of what you know people
call transmedia i call it a sin
experience and i'll tell you why in a
second
but like i learned like this has always
been in my dna like how to create like
basically how to build out story worlds
um and so um you know if you go to an
amusement park and they do it well
they'll create different sorts of
experiences throughout the park you know
like for instance you go to disney world
you have like you know frontierland
um you know you'll have like different
sorts of things in it but if you're in
frontierland you're gonna eat barbecue
everybody's
dressed in western gear it looks that
way so i started to develop my
my um film properties pretty much the
same way that i was going to build out a
story world just not a linear storyline
where people could be entertained with
different facets of the of the uh
of the content uh so people can jump and
jump out of the storyline and everything
else
um but it was interesting though is um
as a kid
i started to realize certain business
things
um where i was outside of an office one
day
and i heard my two uncles debating about
who was gonna get the syrup contract
between coke and pepsi
and so i'm like hmm that's interesting
because they're exactly the same price
right
it all came down to how much free stuff
that we were gonna get
and so and that's really what the
deciding factor was is how much free
merch they were gonna get and i'm like
huh that's interesting and so from day
one of my filmmaking career i've always
had product placement all my films
and it's been something that it's one is
i feel like it
makes this story that much more
authentic because you're using real
product
but then number two is you get a bunch
of free stuff you know
and then with billboard we ended up even
them even giving us money for things too
so living in a you know living you know
as a family had an amusement park it
gave me a completely different
sensibility than a lot of my peers have
what did watching your grandfather's
business teach you about sponsorship
um okay it's interesting cause my
grandfather
um helped build it but that was his his
brothers and sisters that ran it
so it was interesting because my
grandfather was pushed out of his will
because
my grandfather wanted to raise his kids
instead of
being raised in the park so he was
completely ostracized from the park
um early on so we had to work it
and everything because it was a family
tradition uh but my grandfather never
got any riches from it whatsoever he got
when his
when his father passed away he got 500
bucks
and you know that's it's the way it is
that's what it was so i just want to
make sure that you realize it wasn't my
grandfather was actually my uncle's
answer running it
okay um but um uh
it it taught me a lot it taught me a
matter of one is
taking care of people's is very
important uh
realizing that you know it is a business
even though we're in show
uh it makes you realize that you know
all the hard work that goes into it you
know the park opens at you know 12
o'clock
we're there at eight the park closes at
uh you know at ten o'clock we're there
till two you know so it's just a matter
of like so long hours
we're par for the course um but it's
also interesting too is like how much
ingenuity
took place uh and also it's a matter of
um
like my great-grandfather end up having
a bunch of patents on on
on different sorts of concession things
uh and which is kind of interesting um
and um but also two was like you had to
change with the times
and it's interesting because in the film
industry people are so afraid to change
where and i'm a very early adopter of a
lot of stuff that's why i've always been
uh and in the entertainment or in the
amusement business you have to be the
same way you have to constantly be fresh
you have to be new
you can't be boring or else people are
going to come year after year
you can't have the same old rides you
have to do something different you know
new spectacles
when you saw that he put in all this
hard work and then in the end
maybe it didn't turn out exactly the way
he had planned or or maybe it wasn't
that important to him did it teach you a
lot about
putting sort of all your energy and hope
into something and maybe it'll work out
and maybe it wouldn't
and being still able to take that risk
kind of being free of like
whatever the outcome is um we were
our born risk takers we're also
um we work very hard
and we will persevere like it's almost
like there's a line of stubbornness
that you'll keep working and reworking
and doing whatever you can to make it
work
um and you know sometimes you have to
pivot uh in a different direction to
make it work
um but it's just a matter of if you are
honest you work hard
and you have a vision you basically do
whatever you can to make that
that vision happen like my grandfather
um because there's officers from his own
family
started a kitty land at an airport you
know the allentown airport
and it was interesting because people
still talk about it and my grandfather
literally built all the rides himself
uh he built all the concession stands
himself and it was open from
may until september and my mom and all
of her sisters how to work it and things
so it's kind of interesting like it's in
our blood it's in our dna to kind of
like do this sort of thing and to
persevere and to do what you had to do
to make it
um but it's a matter of like you know
like he was you know kind of like shun
from his own family which is pretty sad
so i think we already talked about this
but i'll just okay
how many revenue streams does an
amusement park have
gosh uh well you have first of all you
have admission
right and then you generally will have
um your amusement whether it be a ride
or an entertainment like let's say it's
like
like a song with dance routine or
something like that but then you have
merchandise
you have your games of chance and you
have food
an interesting thing is is um dorney
park was founded
as um it was a catering company first my
family moved over here from france in
the 1800s they're all butchers
and to sell more food they brought in
the carousel
and that's how the whole park started
was literally started out as
a food operation and to sell more food
they built amusements and my
great grandfather came very friendly
with walt disney uh because their boats
were right next door to each other in
fort lauderdale and florida
and um and when when disney was building
you know disney world in
orlando um it was um it was interesting
because you know
disney had a completely different view
on what he was doing versus what my
grandfather was doing
disney was a dreamer my grandfather was
a money maker
uh and and his his sole purpose was
really to entertain but as you entertain
people
people forget about what they're
spending and they spend more money oh
that's a great point
you know and it's kind of it's it's it's
like one of those things and and so
um i'm not saying that every amusement
park is built the way that my
grandfather
my great grandfather built his but
that's that that was like literally the
dna of it so it wasn't originally
supposed to be an amusement park it was
to sell more food so the food was
unbelievable and so then you also
understand why
he had all these patents on concessions
like you know would like ketchup mustard
dispensers that would like basically
turn and
the condiment and flow out he actually
patented the um
waffle iron that flips all these weird
things just to be able to sell more
more food so when it comes to filmmaking
which would you say you are
the walt disney model or your
grandfather's
ooh
wow um
[Laughter]
i'd say both because it's funny because
i write
direct and produce i will produce other
people's work but i'll i will direct
what i write
uh and end up producing it as well um
but um i am a dreamer as a disney and i
do create everything from scratch
um but at the same time i'm very
practical like for instance with
billboard we ended up driving revenue
very early on
to the project we were cash flow
positive before we ever shot any film
because we ended up selling billboard
spaces throughout the content
uh and so i mean mind you it costs a lot
more than just the billboard spaces you
know like we you have i have a bunch of
money wrapped up in it
but so i'm a pragmatist and also a
dreamer at the same time
i think that's what's made me somewhat
successful is because i can think both
ways
and at the same time if i know that i
have to make that dream happen
i will work my butt off to make it
happen that makes sense
so why get into filmmaking rather than
join a family business or start
something else
um i've been a storyteller since i've
been a kid trying to get myself out of
trouble
generally um and so i
always loved telling stories i've been a
writer since i've been little
and then having a lot of um things
happen uh
to me uh i would base express myself
through writing
and then i found um filmmaking to be
something that i thoroughly enjoyed
because
it brought a lot of my uh passions
together like i love
the whole building of sets and things
and building the world i love the whole
costuming part of it i love
you know the acting part of it and it's
just like so there's so much about it
that i thoroughly enjoy
and when i was younger i actually want
to be an actor and so i did a bunch of
acting i actually was in
john waters film hairspray as one of the
corny collins council members
um and um and so uh but i didn't pursue
acting
um too deep i got very close to a major
role
and because i did not get it gave me
cold feet and i never acted again
uh and so i have a lot of respect for
actors um i
direct actors that i will only let them
do what i would do
and i will never risk my crew members
and so like i will only take like for
instance in billboard there's these
you know really crazy winter shots that
i went out and shot at myself
because i would not risk my crew that's
just the way i am you know and so um
filmmaking has always been it's not been
it's not something that i grew up
wanting to do
it's something that i gravitated towards
uh because i wanted to tell stories and
i wanted to affect people
um i wanted to like inspire them um you
know store emotions and just provoke
thought
and that's pretty much why i'm a
filmmaker
so when you were like skateboarding
around allentown or whatever with your
mohawk or yeah
it was your sex pistols t-shirt or
whatever yeah
um did you have any idea of how you
wanted your life to be did you want to
be a musician or you still want to be an
actor at that time and
do something well actually it's funny
because even when i was when i was a
a punker i still wanted to basically go
to wall street
i still really want it yeah i love i
love business i really love business
like i i
um i go to conferences um you know
startup conferences and things
um and it's funny because i speak at you
know a lot of different colleges and
and i'm doing a pretty intensive thing
at wharton in a couple of weeks
um because how i create is very
different than my peers and also
how i make money is very different than
my peers and so
um i would say i'm pretty much still
pretty much a business person uh but
i have this creative itch that i'm
constantly scratching it's like poison
ivy and it's getting all over me
uh but it's it's one of those things
that um that you know i just love to
pursue
you know but i love tell i love my very
first film affairs
um was very mediocre um but it um
uh did very well financially uh and the
crazy thing is it's like it's like you
know got me
you know on the sundance radar not that
it was not at sundance
but because i produced it and because i
made money at it i was invited to the
sundance producers conference
i announced that to my first film um and
um and so i kind of held that same sort
of
uh um model that same sort of equation
from my early films i still hold today
what was it about ferris was about the
um
was about exactly what it says is
affairs
so and affairs ended up being another
film that i ended up doing later on
called in search of
so it's about the repercussions the
consequence of people's sexual actions
uh affairs was kind of like um like a
flirtation of it it was only a 74-minute
film
shop in black and white um and
everything kind of like wrapped around
that you were finally realized this is
an entire family
um that these little vignettes all
circled around thanksgiving dinner
oh wow so yeah because it came to me
after
being away from home for a while and
going home and realizing that i had no
clue what my brothers and sisters were
doing
that's the genesis of the of the script
was like wow i wonder what they're doing
and everything else and stuff and i
hopefully they weren't doing half the
crazy stuff i came up with my mind but
you know so be it what were some of the
biggest mistakes you made early on
in your filmmaking career rushing um
early on i would rush through script i
would rush into production
at rush shoot post so i could share it
um
that's probably my biggest problem is
that like for instance i this project
called aka
that i rushed into production because my
dad always wanted to be in the movie and
he was dying of cancer
so um i literally wear my heart on my
sleeve with a lot of things that i do
and reasons why i do certain things um
but
that was probably my biggest lesson
learned and so now like i take my time
i believe in story r d where i like to
make things or break things
test them in front of audiences and see
what's working what's not working
um like for instance with billboard we
have a web series part of this that we
tested in front of a live audience where
we staged it you know as a play
i never staged a play before in my life
but i just did it what the hell you know
it was successful it was crazy it was
interactive play where the audience
interacted with the
characters via social media on one
screen above the billboards was um
the information that the billboard
sitters were putting out
on another screen is what the audience
is putting in and some of the action on
the stage was
was improv based off of that
correspondence
i mean the actors weren't literally
tweeting and stuff we had a whole other
team doing all that kind of stuff but it
was just very interesting very dynamic
it was an experiment but it's
interesting what we learned from it was
how the audience was reacting to the
material that would then become the web
series
you know you think about it like
filmmaking should really take a little
bit more of a
thought about what tv does in terms of
film before a live studio audience right
so just like what tv does what do they
do they rehearse it for the first three
days they bring it into
a you know to a live audience they tape
it four times they change some
some stuff up if something's not hitting
right and then they they finally
they finally do the taping you know the
end taping the last two the last two uh
tapings i should say
um and i think filmmaking should take a
little bit of that uh like for instance
with billboard we
did sneak previews this past fall to
test our audience
because we thought we knew who our
audience was based off of earlier test
screenings and then also doing
a b testing with facebook ads and so
forth but we wanted to make sure that
was it and making sure that they
responded to the material and so
we did a bunch of sneak previews to test
what the
how the artist was reacting to the
material making sure that our test
audiences were the actual audience
in fact we even you know i actually end
up shooting two scenes
uh that end up in the final film so i
firmly believe in story r d
and so now the lesson learned was not
rush but actually take your time
and also too is like not having all the
resources at your disposal also
warrants taking your time as well um the
other lesson i learned too was a matter
of
uh empowering people to be successful uh
teach them all that you can and then
hand the objective over to them and and
you know
make sure they hit their tasks um and i
still have the same sort of uh
you know organizational stuff that i had
from my very first film i mean you have
to realize like i learned by doing
i didn't learn this stuff in school
because i had like one semester of film
school
behind me so i literally learned by
doing uh and so over the course of the
years i think i've become a better and
better filmmaker
um and um i've lost my arrogance
i don't think filmmakers should be
arrogant i think they really need to
listen to their audience and and figure
out
uh who they're actually appealing to how
did you know you were rushing through
your first film and
the whole process like what was it
feedback was it an epiphany you had
or just me watching my own material you
know i think that filmmakers need to be
honest with themselves
uh and not everything it makes going to
be great but at the same time everything
you make should be
a testing ground for your next project
we are filmmakers it's a craft
people don't remember we were we're
craftsmen
crafts ladies you know and so it's a
matter of and
with film you bring all these different
craftspeople together to be able to
create one
one piece of work um and
it's one of those things that people
don't think about enough and and i
always talk
to a bunch of students and say like
listen like you'll learn more by doing
than you will in school
you know because you have to do it you
have to fail you have to figure out what
works that doesn't work
but i learned that i was rushing through
things by watching stuff myself
after the fact you know i was i was a
bit naive a bit arrogant and thinking
that you know
what i would make would make money and
and thankfully it all has
um it's interesting it's like i have a
very different business model i keep
saying that
but um like all my films have been
profitable except for one and it's the
only film that we sold
you know it's very strange you know
because i i firmly believe in theatrical
distribution um you know i believe in in
what i call a ten thousand dollar
screening
where you were actually netting ten
thousand dollars out of screening
uh so like you know we'll have this like
i'll rent the largest place possible
you'll sell as many tickets as we can we
tier the ticket prices
you know ten dollars 35 125
that's 125 um and so we
um for instant ten dollars just get you
in the film 35 is the film and after
party
know the 125 is a pre-party screening
and after party and then also like you
know like swag bags sorts of stuff
uh then we hand out film bills that we
sell advertising in
uh i literally make all that i really
have merch and all these sorts of things
so i literally will net
at least 10 grand you know per screening
um and i generally do that in the early
early parts of of
film release and i've been successful at
it so you do you string
no number of those together you're in
the black um
and um you know so it's like just a
model that i've created for myself
and i also have some i always have some
other sort of ip involved
like friends with aka i told you about
earlier the film tanked
it didn't do well but i made more money
on a cocktail book that i
made associated with the project than i
did on the film itself
uh but i still equate that to the phone
because it's all part of the insane the
same property
uh so i always think about like creating
different revenue streams for every
project
um like for instance with billboard you
know we have i created a radio station
uh wtyt960 we have the web series we
have
now the interactive play and we have the
feature film
and then with all that stuff we can sell
um you know
sponsorships yeah because we're actually
you know showing off brands within the
content that we've created
uh and so that drives a whole other
level of income
how many sponsorships do you have for
billboard
um four
six seven eight
there's nine nine sponsors uh yeah and
and and i'll be very
candid uh they go anywhere from
uh 9 000 up to 40
000. i see so that and
9 000 is your minimum entry point yeah
and do you know
that's fantastic did you have prior
business relationships with any of the
sponsors or
you just cold call or cold call but also
too is like i firmly believe that
filmmakers need to build audience early
on and so what we did first is we
created the radio station wtyt 960
where now there's well over a thousand
bands on it from i think we're in 22
countries
49 states uh and so i did that was
so i knew that we could that we had an
audience
and no sponsor is going to give you
anything unless you could prove
that they're going to have impression
counts unless they know that they're
going to have some sort of audience for
the project
so not only do we have those thousand
bands but then we have their fans
and we did we did a we did an average of
them and each of the bands
averaged at least six thousand fans so
all of a sudden
you know a thousand bands and six
thousand fans you're at you know what
six million
uh reach you know which is pretty
astronomical for a small independent
film uh and so we were able to get those
numbers because we could prove that we
actually had you know impressions
uh and so we had audience and that's
what's that's what's pretty fascinating
about all that because it's not easy to
do
but we were able to do it with the film
screenings where you said you netted
10 grand uh what's your split with the
theater like how are you working i read
them
you rent them so you buy it out and yeah
okay so there's
so much again mind you that's not every
screening that we do is 10 grand
early on we do we do um it's interesting
because we found that
we do better at events when we have
events around our projects than we do
just like
you know running a week or something
like that so we're going to be you know
like reformulating that model a little
bit and taking it on the road
uh but like what we do is like we will
launch the film
by that ten thousand dollar screening
because then that also tools frees up
capital
and also builds buzz that we then have a
very good box office
uh and that's how that's how it all how
it's all generated
so i've written about this a couple of
times like i wrote something for ted
hope's blog
about the ten thousand dollar screening
and things and um it's very possible
every filmmaker could do it
and they really can uh interesting thing
is is because
i produce and i create outside of so far
outside the system
of new york and la that there's
anomalies that
happen because of that like i don't know
if you could do it in l.a
quite honestly is because there's so
many filmmakers making so many films
here
that i don't know if it would work nor
in new york but it does work
where i'm from yeah so i was just going
to ask you so so
do you have such a leg up because it's a
smaller area they want to support local
artists
they're excited maybe they're even in
the film uh
yeah it's absolutely to a point but at
the same time um
again it has its pluses and minuses um
you know it's harder for me to produce
in my hometown
because of that really well because i
have to bring in everybody you know like
there is colleges that have
um you know film programs but i end up
teaching everybody and then once i teach
them
they stick around for a couple years
then they come to la you know because i
i
because i don't produce enough work you
know fast enough to be able to sustain
like full-time people
over the course of a long period of time
so we end up bringing in people from new
york
philadelphia you know for crew and also
some cast then we also fly casting from
la
so that's a problem it's like when
you're producing in places that are more
remote
um they do cost more people don't think
about that you know catering per diem
lodging uh transportation uh but then
also tools that people be like oh
you get you know tax incentives and yada
yada yada but you only get those if you
qualify for them
and so there is a certain thing that you
have to be aware of and again it comes
down to the business side of things
um like for instance i produce off of
cash flow not many filmmakers do that
uh so i don't qualify for a lot of um
tax incentives because i don't have
you know the eight hundred thousand
dollars in the bank you know
after july first after they passed their
uh past their their budget
you know i basically you know make money
and spend money that's my business model
and so i don't qualify okay yes so it's
a matter of
um underst like if for instance like
producing outside of like new york and
la
and and atlanta um feminists just really
need to know
what their state tax incentive is before
they even you know start thinking about
budgeting
it all shows where they're getting their
capital from um you know there's also
different
you know tricks and everything else that
you can do to be able to make to
to obtain capital i am horrible at
crowdfunding
i have a hard time asking people for
money i think that's one reason why
i have very few equity partners and what
i do
i generally spend my own money my wife
and my money
quite frankly um like we are um
about
82 of the of the resources that it took
to make billboard
um and so um but i believe it all in
like i feel like i need to have skin in
the game but i'm so i'm horrible at
asking people for money
horrible i need another producer to ask
for money i can make the money trust me
i can make money just a matter of like i
have a hard time asking people for money
well then there's two probably maybe you
feel freedom too if you know okay well
this is also
literally my or our project you know if
it's your money if it's 80
your money there's less need to get
approval
from other people for things oh you're
actually absolutely right
uh but at the same time there's a lot
more risk there's a lot more sleepless
nights you know i'm worried about making
payroll i'm worried about like literally
people watch the film
uh my my um you know the people that
work with me
said it's become a bit autobiographical
and it's interesting is because we've
been screening the film
um with much success thank god and um
you know some people push back like oh
they don't like the ending and things
and i'm like you know i understand that
and and once they
then they they'll tend to argue with me
in a q a which doesn't make any sense to
me but like but like
and and so like i literally asked him a
simple question have you ever owned a
business
well um i'm like no have you ever owned
a business have you ever
had to make payroll well
my father did but did you
well my father lost his business i'm
like exactly exactly
and so the thing is it's like it's like
people really can't walk the walk unless
they've talked the talk was or they
screwed that around you know they talk
to talk unless they walk the walk
you know and so like my wife and i
literally we put everything on the line
it's it's it's it's scary as hell it's
risky as hell
um but i've made money in the past so i
keep doing it
um you know thank god you know like we
have been successful and also too is
like people can't look at filmmaking as
a lottery i have so many friends with so
many peers that see getting into science
as a lottery ticket
that like you know they're gonna like
have this huge career and everything
else and
and and that sort of thing i love snow
and dance i've had films at sundance
that's not what i'm saying at all
but it's a matter of people have to look
at the long tail of their careers that
everything is a building block
and you don't want to be a flash in the
pan um because there's only a few of
them
like you can probably name them on your
on on your two hands right
and so how many films have been produced
over the past 10 years
um that have gone nowhere you know and
so people have to think about it more
from
a business perspective um and
realizing how they can make money at it
um early on
and it's just a matter of um not looking
at it as like oh my god i'm gonna make
this movie i'm gonna be rich
but looking at it as i'm making a movie
this is part of my business
you know like if you make widgets you
might make different widgets over the
course of your of your factory's career
right if you're a filmmaker you're gonna
make different films over the course of
your career
it's not all dependent upon one film you
know so just think about it that way
it's not it's not like
and i'm not saying that i've been hugely
successful you know but i've made money
you know and i do this full time you
know and and
you know but it's a grind i work my butt
off still to this day
um you know and i lead by example i'm
the first one in my studio at 7 00 a.m
and i'm
generally the last one to leave at 6 30
7 o'clock you know i've been doing that
for 10 years
you know working on the same project you
know so it's a matter of vision it's a
matter of of
of just really working and and yeah it's
six and a half days a week
i want to go back to what you said about
arrogance and i'm wondering
if that is actually a good trait to have
in the beginning whether you're a
filmmaker entrepreneur or whatever
and then it's good to soften no
no i think i think arrogance any
any filmmaker that's arrogant so there's
a misconception arrogance and confidence
i've never known enough to be arrogant
but i was born confident
i'm still extremely confident what i do
uh but i'm not arrogant enough to say
that i'm the best thing next to sliced
bread
you'll find filmmakers to this day that
walk with air of arrogance
that are successful but at the same time
it's a matter of like you can kind of
see
after after time that that star
starts to fade a bit you know and that
they're that
people start to understand the real
their real selves
so like i'm saying like a matter of like
when i was talking about arrogance
before is a matter of
don't be so arrogant that you lose sight
of who your audience is or think that
you're better than your audience and
that your audience will find
you you need to find your audience it's
a completely different sort of idea
you know so like a matter of like me
creating something so esoteric
that i didn't have a clear vision but i
passed it off as like this next great
thing
because of my arrogance and expecting
people to be willing to see it
is the wrong way of looking at
your career looking at the way of of
creation
you know what i mean like like it's like
it's like do you think the kooning
in his abstract impressionism really
thought do you ever thought for a day
that he was arrogant
or was he trying to do something nobody
else was doing in a fit
you're two totally different things i
think you know in terms of people
rallying around an artist or something
like that yeah they could
air up and they could become arrogant
because of their accreditation that
other people are giving them
but you can't be arrogant as a sole
creator
you know like you can't you can't like
expect people to do something if you
if you haven't risen to that does that
make sense
you know it's like it's like it's like
the whole idea of of um
you know if if if people prop you up
yeah you can become
like arrogant i'm not saying that's
warranted by any means but what i'm
saying is a matter of like don't ever
lose sight of your audience or where
your base was you know like there's been
so many filmmakers that have made it and
gotten to a higher
echelon but then forgot about you know
what got them there and what
sensibilities their audience found
in them early on in their careers why do
you think you were born confident
well i was conceived on the the day that
man landed on the moon
i mean it's crazy i mean i know that
because my my biological father
um uh was a um
in fashion and so he wasn't around much
um
and uh my mom just knows that that was
the day that i was
conceived um and uh but it's interesting
that you asked that question is because
um
he was a raging alcoholic and beat the
living [ __ ] out of myself and my mom
and um i think that's one reason why
i've become extremely confident was
because
of knowing that my mom and i can get
through anything
together my mom's still a very big part
of my life today uh
and it's a matter of when you've been
beaten
you realize that you have to have inner
strength to carry on
and it's just one of those things that
it's like it's like you know
um yeah i'm confident because i know
i i will persevere i will overcome
you know and that's just the thing it's
like it's like you know it's funny i
don't mind that i got beat
i really pisses me off my mom
you did and that's the thing it's like
it's like it's i don't know how to
explain it like
even when you know i was adopted about
my stepfather and that's how i got the
name zeke zelker
and um and uh and he would
become abusive to me but i was happy
that it was taking his his frustration
out on me and not my mom
um and um and i still this day
i don't resent it it really weirdly i
don't resent it because i would have
rather taken that beating than my mom
had anything um and it's just one of
those things that when when
when when you know as a kid like i was
never bullied
i was eccentric and everything else
because i think wanted to be more afraid
of me
um you know because i never backed down
from any con conflict i just never did
uh i think because of that you know and
it's funny because like that's
one reason why i think i can lead is i
can leave big crews and i know what i
want i know the direction i want to take
i've got vision because
the whole idea is like when you're
cowering in a corner
you have to figure out a way to get the
hell out of that corner you know and
stand back up and then keep fighting and
so that's kind of like why
you know i think i've quite say probably
those beatings is what's what's gotten
to me to where i am today
you think that's why you got into punk
rock because it's very um you know part
of it no i got out of that because we
were poor
i mean i got out of that because because
um it was
um not necessarily a sign of aggression
but it was literally because
we i couldn't afford izod i couldn't
afford guest jeans
yeah and so we would go to thrift stores
i know it sounds crazy but but like
but like also too i like the aesthetic i
like the kind of like fu attitude
i still do that's one reason why i cast
the cast members that i did
because they all have that kind of fu
mentality all you know
my four uh bigger names um but um
i do what i guess i like that music like
even you know wtyt is an independent
you know alternative rock radio station
that we created um
so i do gravitate towards that but i
wouldn't say that that aggressiveness
was because
of being beat as a kid we want to play
a video a recent video it's with another
gentleman who does transmedia or talks
about transmedia
and his name is houston howard and he's
an author
and an instructor here at la film school
and this video as of many um videos with
houston
has done incredibly well so we want to
play it it's got a lot of comments here
so all that to get back to saying if
you're the
the small independent producer that has
a low budget you have to figure out a
way to compete
you have to figure out a way to survive
to thrive
to exist in this market and it's tough
to out punch everybody
you can't overpower star wars you can't
overpower fortnite
or or any of these other things now you
have to be craftier right so you can't
just
inundate the world with marketing with
with posters with trailers you can't buy
tv spots
so what can you do and so if you have a
good idea
if you have a good story and you're a
great storyteller now
there's all these really interesting
tools that we can use
to now send your story out and capture
the attention of the audience
right and so it's not necessarily about
putting one fishing lure out there now
now that we have so many tools we can
have 10 or 12 fishing lures out there
uh simultaneously fishing in 12
different ponds
all all the time looking for audience
and
uh and so what i get though is
independent creators
saying one i don't know how to do it or
even if they know how to do it they say
uh that seems like a lot of work
right and that like that to me that
is is such the wrong mindset to have
right because we talked about this in
the first round of interviews we did
is i always encourage independent
filmmakers to be thinking as
entrepreneurs
rather than just an artist and because
when you're when you're
creating ip when you're creating uh
when you're launching a film you're
launching a small business
you're you're setting up an llc you're
staffing it with a crew
and you're creating something and
you have to think of yourself just like
the guy who's open in the coffee shop
or the woman that's opening the pizza
shop or the family that's opening of the
candle store down the street
you have to have that same mentality and
so though like
if you understand the amount of hours
and hard work it is to launch your own
business
then you you the independent filmmakers
understand it in in context of a film
they're fine with spending 18 hours a
day on a film set for you know 12
straight days
that's fine because that's they think
that's just within the context of what
they do
but now it's broadened to where now you
have to learn how to
uh you have to learn how to broaden the
scope of that to have a
have more more skill sets at your
disposal
in order to compete in this crazy market
so as a pizza shop owner
can't say well uh i love to make pizza
that's my thing
i'm not going to worry about the
bookkeeping because you know
who cares about that or i'm not going to
worry about
you know the front of the house i'm not
going to worry about these other things
all i'm going to do is make my pizza
the business owner the chef may but the
business owner has to concern themselves
with
everything they have to know the full
scope of everything
and they have to be able to put in the
hours and the work
to be able to figure that stuff out if
they want a successful business
and even even when they do that most
small businesses fail
and they fail primarily either because
of lack of quality or they don't figure
those other things out
right they can't figure out how to
compete and so so
it's such an audacious thing to say you
want to be a filmmaker for the rest of
your life
this is your dream and what you want to
do is you want to live your life
professionally making movies for the
rest of your life
that is such a first world crazy dream
to have
which is an awesome dream that that if
it's in your heart
100 percent go for it but you have to
understand
how rare that is and how audacious that
is
and the big disconnect with especially
independent filmmakers
is they have this audacious dream of how
they want to live the rest of their life
just making the movie like their own
movies and that's their job forever
they have this audacious dream but at
the same time
don't want to go the same
audacious route to be able to put in the
work to learn all the stuff you need to
do to compete to do
to make that happen right and what they
say to me is they say well
tarantino didn't do that i mean
tarantino broke in like you know
beyonce doesn't do this or like they
they point to
they point to these people that one
broke in
in a different era first of all like
we talk about how fast things change now
like
things have changed from 2019 like 2015
to 2019 completely different
let alone when tarantino broke in in the
mid 90s
right like you it's not the same world
it's not the same thing
and and the problem that i think people
have is they look at
tarantino or they look at scorsese
they'll look at these people scorsese
doesn't do trans media i don't need to
do transmedia right
wow okay so um uh
i think he read my blog post about
um independent filmmaking as a startup
i literally paralleled how um startup
companies
uh how filmmaking is a lot like startup
culture
where you've got a bootstrap and
everything else um i disagree with the
idea
of um beyonce because beyonce busted her
butt since she was a kid
working hard at what she was doing um
tarantino had somebody that believed in
him
and funded him and also because you're
so eccentric
and those eccentricities do
attract people and
the whole idea of transmedia is
i don't not doing transmedia because of
to try and drop other lures into the
pond
to fish i do it because it's innate to
my storytelling
i create transmedia um
projects which i call student
experiences
because i want to build out story worlds
i want to tell a different part
point of view a different part of the
story in a different way
i do it's interesting he has a lot of
different things that i talk about all
the time like
i think film schools students in film
schools need to take a
programming class uh cs classes uh and
they also need to take a class in
marketing
a class in accounting and a class in law
those are all things that i do a lot of
almost on a daily basis
and i think that film schools are are
improperly
educating their students for what it's
really like out there
um it's interesting because he also
talks about about
building out audiences and doing
different things but i firmly believe
that it's actually audience building
early on
and you take that audience through a
series of events
not necessarily like trying to pick out
different elements and hoping you're
going to find audience
i want to take audiences along for a
ride i don't necessarily want them just
to be entertained by this little thing
and this little thing over
there um it's just i just have a
different business model
um uh
yeah i do agree with a lot of things
that he's saying especially from the
business standpoint
but in terms of of i'm not certain i got
anything about like
transmedia producing though quite
honestly okay well if he has other
videos we could we could okay
i wanted to follow up on something uh
why why uh coding and why law though
those of the i get the marketing part
but
well i do a lot all the time because you
deal with contracts everything's
contractual
people don't realize you need to clean
china title for a film and people don't
probably don't understand what i'm i'm
saying right now and that's why i need
to know
law is because if you're selling a
property
you need to literally make sure that
that that you have a clear chain of
title when you have a
film property it's an ip just like you
have a piece of real estate right
that's property property right and so
you need to basically make sure your
copyright's in place you have to make
sure that you know you you did a title
check you have to make sure all these
sorts of things so you can then
if you if you end up selling your film
to a distributor you have a clean chain
of title
uh but law like you know like your
contracts your music contracts your
actor you know
deal memos like there's so much law i
deal with it it's it's insane
i mean i do have attorneys not to say
that i'm my only attorney
i won't say that at all but then with
coding because we've become such a
um film and technology are
merging so quickly that i think there's
a lot of opportunity lost that people to
understand what coding is and how it
does like i can't code myself
when i was younger i knew more coding
i do understand the concepts i
understand you understand all these
sorts of things
and i can literally articulately
articulate what i want a coder to do and
what i want to achieve and i know enough
about it to get myself in trouble
um but like ces is so important now
because
um you have stories that can be told
through apps
you know it's another device you can use
as a storytelling tool
um and that's kind of why i say you know
cs
i think when he was talking about
tarantino and beyonce i guess
he was trying to say uh and maybe it's
the point of where we started the video
that that most filmmakers already think
some
some filmmakers think right out of the
gate that they are at that level that's
the arrogance
okay he was trying to say that
people aren't that yet if we've played
it further yeah so that so just
just as a caveat or whatever but
um so i think that that going back right
everyone thinks that well
my esoteric idea is is just totally
different and
they're going to come to me i don't need
to go to them kind of thing so
no i i it's funny because i i
i agree with him with that it's a matter
of um
you have to look at this as a business
you know each one of your each one of
your
films is a new business like and the one
thing is it's like i don't
necessarily sell my films i license them
but i don't sell them so i still own all
the rights to all my projects
you've never sold one i sold one the
only film i didn't make money on
so you sold it to a distributor did you
do sort of due diligence did you
research
the distributor make sure the other
producers went against what i wanted
i was straight up and and so forth and
and um
and um it just is what it is it's i
don't know how else to explain it
you know just a business decision that
they made they had more more you know
skin in the game than i did um but um
but yeah
it's just one of those things so like i
look at it as a long game just like
how these different sorts of
distributors own all this content
and that's what gives them uh wealth or
value
it's the same sort of thing with my
dream machine it's like we own a bunch
of content that eventually i could sell
off if i wanted to
you know but i retain all the rights to
all my stuff you learned from that
initial
experience even though you didn't have
the the stake in the decision
that no more distribution deals you'll
license it
but you're going to ultimately own it
was that the final sort of verdict
yeah yeah um yeah well yeah it's it's um
i don't know how to explain it um
i've never been short-sighted i guess
i've always looked at it as
as a long view have i wished that like
i've made millions of my projects
absolutely
um but at the same time i still have a
career and i've been doing this for 20
years
um you know so there's something that
i'm doing right but i got to tell you
it's all because of the business
acumen that i have uh it's also my
creative too
i shouldn't discount my creative because
i do do some crazy stuff
um and um you know and i'm you know a
natural born promoter i think
you know as well um but it's interesting
because i
the reason that i got really deep into
transmedia
was because i realized that the
audiences were fragmenting
meaning that for me to reach an audience
i couldn't just tell of a feature film
that went into theaters i had to create
stories that people could also view on
mobile devices
i wanted to create a way that people
could
use the different screens and i wanted
to tell a different part of the story on
each of those screens
um you know when i was releasing in
search of the entire industry fell apart
you know all the distributors went to
hell you know the stock market crashed
everything else and
and so like i had to kind of pick up the
pieces um and it was a very expensive
film to make
uh in search of was and um and so i had
to figure out how i was gonna make money
and that's why i was an early adopter to
all these all these um digital platforms
and so forth
um but um you know so i came to
transmedia one is i've been doing it i
think all my life and
the term never was coined uh henry
jenkins at mit was a person that coined
the term transmedia um and um and uh but
i'm just
as i said i'm getting away from that
term i'm calling it a cine experience
because i also do live events and
everything else around it as well
which also generates more capital you
know so for instance what we're doing is
with the um
wto t960 the radio station that we
created for the con
for the for the project is we then hold
live events with the bands
you know so we obviously charge
admission we pay the bands you know we
have a
we have a great time so but that's yet
another revenue stream that we've
created
what do you think people get wrong about
transmedia what do most filmmakers fail
uh well i got to tell you um i debate
some very
big people in the transmedia space and
they
are arms of marketing
they're generally brought in after the
fact after the property's been made to
actually help market the film
where the way that i do it is built into
the story dna early on
and it's interesting because i've had at
agencies that have come to me
to create transmedia elements around
a given property and i can do it pretty
quickly just because again my family
background i can't
i i can't i can't escape that because i
just was raised a different way that
this is built into my vision this is
built into like
how i create you know all my films i've
done this and
and and it's just really weird that that
um
that um and i know it works and doesn't
work the biggest thing is like you can't
create a lot of friction for your
audience
a lot of transmedia producers they want
to do this and want to do that no
wouldn't this be cool oh we should do
that
the problem is is the more friction that
you create for your audience the less
audience you're going to have
you actually have to kind of of of be
open
and also lessen
the suspension of belief
the more real you can make something the
easier it is for your audience to
actually
believe in it and want to participate in
in in all the content
for instance if you do a like a sci-fi
um project transmedia project you have
to suspend belief before you even
start to play with the elements of the
creation right
because it's sci-fi it's not real right
and so
um so you have to suspend belief and
then also you put these hurdles in place
that
people have to go to x y and z and then
do this and do that
to be able to um you know get the
content
you're asking a lot of your audience and
i know for a fact because we i've done
this i've
we have case studies behind it and
things that you have to create the least
amount of friction possible for your
audience
for them to buy into it like people when
they go to our shows don't realize
they're
stepping into my into my film world it's
kind of cool
but they still don't you know get it
until they're there for a bit
so sorry let me see if i understand
friction so friction would be where
there's like sort of too many
things going on in terms of diverting
attention so that you could create
another story
not necessarily just that but it could
be just something that you have in your
website that you want somebody to view
something and then they have to answer
four questions to be able to unlock a
mystery code to be able to
to then you know access a qr code that
then brings you to a mobile app
that brings you back to a micro it's
like you understand what i'm saying like
all these crazy things for people to do
yeah it's fun it's a puzzle you know we
can do some stuff with ar do the same
sort of idea
but i think you have to simplify it for
the audience because this is new for
people
that's a big thing and so the thing is
it's like it's like um but people have
to be willing to
um you have to make content so
compelling that they want to see the
other parts of it though too
you had to be successful so like with
billboard people are seeing the film and
then they are downloading the web series
um you know again listen to my audience
is like we originally had
28 episodes of the web series
that range anywhere from 90 seconds to 7
minutes
realized that the ux was cumbersome
for the viewers ux meaning user
interface
was too cumbersome for the viewers that
i had to listen to them and i
and i collapsed them down and made nine
longer ones
you know again it's not it's me not
being arrogant
because of i had to listen to my
audience i'm confident in my content and
not afraid
to do that because i can do it but at
the same time it's a matter of like
i realize that i've created friction for
my audience to be able to
uh enjoy that content that we've created
why do you think most filmmakers fail in
the entrepreneurial mindset
they don't think about business you know
it's it's a matter of like i don't think
enough
filmmakers come from a business
background or
i'm not saying that they should come
from business backgrounds but they
should know about business
or at least have one or two people on
their team that
are business people um and
um it's crucial you know um
my wife's a hell of a business woman and
and you know and she keeps me in check
as well
uh and so you need those sorts of things
but i think that and not enough
filmmakers look at it
again like it goes back to the lottery
system like people think they're going
to be tarantino they're going to think
they're going to be
you know scorsese scorsese put his put
his time in
scorsese worked his butt off you know
and and everything else and and
i you know give him mad props you know
because he's constantly making new
material he's constantly changing
you just like just like a musician would
he has like these different sorts of
styles that he's
played with and everything else um but i
just think that
you know filmmakers need to think about
the long game and not the short game
uh that you know they have to realize
that you know
that it's gonna take work it's gonna
take a lot of work
you know and that's the thing it's like
if you're not willing to put in the work
then you might want to choose a
different path
well you've been working on billboard
now for 10 years
so what month in 2009 do you remember
that you
started i announced in october oh okay
okay
of 20 you have 2009. when you first
started
when you announced in in october 2009
did you think it would take you this
long
no what time frame did you think uh i
thought it was going to take me
probably four years um
and how i created this whole thing was
um
i had this idea for the film and um i
was working on a script
uh and it's completely different than
what it is now
and realizing where what happened to in
search of
um i
unraveled a roll of craft paper had a
black sharpie in my hand and mapped out
the entire
billboard project i still have that
piece of craft paper it's pretty
fascinating because how i wanted to
create like the website
for the radio station and like how bands
are going to submit their music
and like how we're going to aggregate
their social media builder profiles
and how the playlist was going to be
formulated and all these sorts of things
and then you know dealing with the web
series and how i was going to shoot that
versus
the film and the only thing that came
that we
did additional to that original um
ideation session was the uh
the interactive play uh that was born
out of us doing a test of something and
i'm like oh my god i can stage this
and so he did uh but i thought that it
was going to take me about four years
uh but i didn't realize i'd have to
educate as many people as
i did about transmedia
and it was just hard to raise money
really hard to raise money and so like
you know the only thing
two things you could throw money on a
problem if you have a lot of it
and not take your time and collapse the
window or you could
take a lot of time if you don't have the
money and make it happen
you know so i i obviously opted for the
latter but it's just a matter of um
of uh you know just seeing it through
and also too is like i'm glad because
you know we shot the film over the
course of nine months because i wanted
seasons to change
um and we were shooting the film uh it
was during the
presidential elections and so and we're
doing this it was originally
was supposed to be a comedy and when we
got into post-production
it just was too heavy it just felt
fat i don't know how to explain it like
just felt uncomfortable
and so we kept pairing it back pairing
it back pairing the fact that i'm
like realizing okay i gotta change this
thing
and so forty percent of the film was
shot with three people
uh myself um uh reed baum who is my
editor and also camera
and then um uh ryan walsh who is a
producer that also ran sound
and so we literally shot 40 of the films
the three of us um
and uh but i'm glad that it took us time
because it let us
um experiment with some things and
figure some stuff out
um and we got some great shots we got
the winner stuff and everything else
because of it the first year you began
uh so like let's say october 2009 to
october 2010
what were you focusing on and building
you're building the radio station
and you're in a recession too yeah yeah
so we so again
going back to the whole coding side of
it was a matter of we created
um wtyt960 um
from scratch you know and so i knew what
i wanted to do
and how and and but i needed somebody
who knew how to do it
i never met her in person but i have a
programmer out of chicago
um that works with me still she's still
working with me
she's been working with with me from the
very beginning of this thing and um
and we had one uh programmer in
australia another one in czech republic
because they didn't want to have one
person have my ip um
and so um you know and she called this
thing together uh but it's very complex
like
programmers that see it and then they
realize like what we did they're like
wow okay this is this is like a complete
build
you know and we did and so we we you
know and the interesting thing is is
like over the course of time when the
social media
um outlets change their apis we didn't
do a whole new build
you know so time kind of screwed us with
that though too was because it would
have been a little bit easier if if we
would have done it in a collapsed
amount of time well i'm sorry why would
you
not want one person to have your ip
because i could steal
it so i was doing something completely
proprietary
that's the thing it's like so so we have
we have stuff on that on the back end
we built stuff um we built new things
new widgets for wordpress
uh and so forth so it's a matter of like
we i did not want
people to to have it quite
quite frankly you know so that's kind of
like why i had i had a team of uh people
that worked on it
so so you had them working on different
parts so they didn't yeah and then and
they cross brought them together
ah okay right so they wouldn't like next
thing you know you don't hear from them
again right now someone's doing the same
thing
gotcha wow that's smart okay yeah and
where did you
who advised you on that that's really i
just did it you just did it you just
knew
like well i just knew like again knowing
the law side of things and realizing
that if one person had my ip the the
the possibility of theft was a lot
greater um
you know and so that's that's why you
know straight up i mean it just is
and and so um you know we spent a lot of
time developing that and then i also
created other ways for
you know other people to get involved
with the project too um
but it's always been like this kind of
um that's why tech is so heavy what i'm
doing
you can't producing in the transmedia
world you can't have
the absence of technology technology
everything rides in the backbone of
technology
so you created you made new widgets for
yeah
yeah and and are these now used for and
anybody can
insert them into their site no no no no
no
but chris chris has across i see okay
what was the hardest part of the 10
years raising money
we never we never were capitalized we
were never we're still aren't
honestly you know um and so like we've
just been
you know um scrappy we've been
bootstrapping the entire time using you
know a startup mentality you know
um and honestly like if we had
you know more capital things would have
been a lot different and quite honestly
probably make more money
but it's just a matter of the nature of
the beast and and how i wanted to do
this
you know because i believe in myself you
know my in my family believes in what
i'm doing too and so you know we're
willing to
you know take those risks um but um
that's
that's probably the hardest thing was
definitely the lack of funding and i
know every filmmaker has that you know
without a doubt
um you know uh and we produced a big
project a big project you know that's
the thing it's like it's like
it's pretty enormous what we've done
like we built a freaking billboard on
the side of a major highway
you know like enough lumber to build a
small house
you know so you have to raise all the
gear up and everything else and like
just from a production standpoint it was
it was
a huge huge undertaking how many
different revenue streams
did you create with billboard
and all the calls okay merchandise
the web series the radio station
live events the film sponsorship
six okay which one was the most
difficult
to make it work
no none no no no not really no i mean i
mean you know like
like because we're still we're still in
release you know like we're still
getting things out there and the thing
is too it's a matter of there's no
there's no like rhyme or reason anymore
there's no rules you know it's
interesting because there's still
gatekeepers a lot of gatekeepers
um like we're having a hell of a time
book theaters uh even though we've made
money
um those gatekeepers at at film
festivals not to say that i want to get
into film festivals
um uh there's gatekeepers every step of
the way
and you just have to figure out a way to
get around them you know just like when
we used to tag you know subways in new
york you know we still got away from
them
or around them they'll be able to do
these sorts of things but it's just it's
like it's like
you know um uh but you're there's
gatekeepers that's probably the biggest
challenge
um for indie filmmakers right now
but in terms of the different sorts of
revenue streams like we're still
we're still in it we're still making
money you know so it's like it's like
and then we're just started
like we're just getting this thing out
there now like people are just starting
to find out about it
you know so which is kind of exciting so
you know we've made money in sponsorship
we've made money in merch
you know um you know we've made money
you know at events like yeah so
it's working it's funny because you said
the gatekeepers and there's like
two catch phrases with any film and that
is the gatekeepers are no longer in
control
and you have to build your audience and
that's really interesting that you say
that
the gatekeepers still they still exist
oh absolutely they do
can you challenge that a little bit yeah
sure so um
oh god where did i start um with film
festivals for instance
um there's gatekeepers and realized too
it's like
you know everybody wants to get into the
big film festivals um and the thing is
is people have to realize that they
program a certain way every year and
that that programming changes
and so what might have gotten into
festival x
in 2015 is not going to get into
festival x in 2016.
and that's the thing so the
sensibilities change so those are
gatekeepers
that you are unaware of how things
change
right and so um
and there's a lot of um
backroom politicking going on a lot of
it
and i'm so far outside the system that i
don't even play in the puddle
the politics i don't know them you know
it's there's gatekeepers
in press or is gatekeepers are trying to
get press there's there's gatekeepers in
terms of
trying to get reviews um you know unless
you're
worthy or something along those lines
will you get reviewed by like a major
outlet
um you know then the theaters have
gatekeepers like you know if you own a
theater they then have a book or that
they put
as as a diversion you know and and so
like okay you gotta appeal to the booker
okay the book or likes then you have to
appeal to the
to the theater um and so um there's all
these yeah imagine they're all business
people right
so they're all business people trying to
do the best they can for their own
individual businesses
um and people like us creative look at
them as like you know
gatekeepers right uh but just a matter
of having sensibilities and if you
complete your case and and understand
what you are selling
um that's a big leg up and actually not
necessarily under
let them know what you are doing but
what you can do for them
the big thing is it's like it's like you
know when you know i now go to
like film festivals i often end up you
know having some sort of talk back or
some sort of educational thing because
people are intrigued of like how i do
what i do
um and you know that's a selling point
for me you know
that that separates me from my peers um
you know
in terms of film festivals um it all
depends on what they're programming and
it's really hard but again it's
it there are there's gatekeepers i don't
know how to explain it and
and it's also too it's like i'm not
coming down at critics by any means
uh because the industry needs them uh
but the interesting
is is because so many budgets have been
cut from media outlets that is fewer and
fewer
and so they can only cover so many
things
but people like me get frustrated by
that and that we don't that doesn't come
to mind right away
uh and you wonder why the hell they
aren't like looking at my
you know my piece you know or they're
not understanding it
um you know and and there's some really
like awesome reviewers out there i'm not
saying that there's not but at the same
time it's a matter of like
somebody that's small that's a first
time out it's gonna be very hard to get
you know recognition and which is which
is a shame
it's really interesting yeah that you
say that the the gatekeeping still
exists even in this realm i think so
many people think
oh independent filmmaking you can be
outside the system you can do whatever
you want but no i'm not
how are you gonna make money you can try
to where hell you want
but how you make money honestly i mean
it comes down to it
if you can't book a theater um you're
not going to make well i
get if you want to go into theaters i
mean because there's so many different
business models i think that's probably
what they're saying
there's no more geek gatekeepers because
there's all these different business
models
but when when push comes to shove you
still have to make money
uh and so you have to figure out how to
facilitate that like right now we're
having a hell of a time trying to get
press
straight up you know and and even though
i'm doing stuff different
even though i've got an interesting
story to tell um
and um it's just a matter of um
you know maybe i'm i'm too assertive i
don't know um but it's just a matter of
like one of those things it's just it's
been a challenge
you know and and i don't i don't know
what to say
maybe i'm not press worthy i don't know
no film school covered you which is i
would say that that's an acclaim right
there
great great site so no be honest i wrote
the article
ah okay okay
still but but they allowed you to have
it there right
absolutely yeah yeah there's another
piece that i wrote too that's gonna be
published by a major outlet as well
okay but the weird thing about it is
like it's like i'm the one writing about
what i'm doing
they're not having somebody cover it
so you understand i mean like so so like
because i have written before and i've
been published before and yada yada yada
so
like i guess that does mean something um
but i've got to be honest with people
like yeah i'm not going to say like oh
yeah they covered me isn't that great
i covered me they're just the outlet
and and again it's like it's like you
know anybody can reach out to me and
i'll catch you
straight you know and and that's a thing
it's a matter of of yes it's an honor
and and and i appreciate them for doing
it i really do
uh because we wouldn't have gotten it
otherwise um you know
and um uh but it's just
it's just true i don't i don't know what
to say it's it's the truth of the matter
i think it's good that people hear that
even if you're quote independent it's
not it's not as independent
as as one would think so no and and it's
like it's like
you know every you know yeah the thing
about it too is like how are these
critics or these or these publications
making money right
you know they're selling advertising uh
and so they only can sell so much
advertising that they have so much
readership
and so that's one reason why two is i
think a lot of the um
normal indie outlets are going more and
more mainstream
uh because then you appeal to the widest
audience possible so they can then have
the readership so they can charge more
money for their ads
it you have to go where the money goes i
i don't know how else to to say it you
know it's
uh and everybody has their own business
models and i understand that uh but at
the same time it doesn't mean that
you know i had you know there was i saw
a couple films of slam dance this past
year
that were just outstanding films that
probably are never going to see the
light of day which is so sad
you know because the filmmakers busted
their butts getting them there
um you know i like them i could find
them on market quite honestly i couldn't
share with their films for them i know i
could
and make money for them um but i don't
i'm still vacillating whether or not i
want to go into that business
um and um and uh
yeah it's it's like because knowing all
the all the other bs i've got to go
through to be able to
make them successful do you think the
politics exist
because you're not in los angeles or do
you don't think that has anything to do
no it does
absolutely it does yeah because um
um it's funny because when i go to film
festivals people from new york
think i'm from l.a people from la think
i'm from new york and then when i say
from allentown pa they're like
what the hell are you doing in allentown
and then i tell them you know my family
you know i tell them the history of it
like oh you're the government on that
you know so
it does differentiate me from the pack
and also too as my
projects are so um authentic
because i don't listen to stuff going on
around me because there isn't any
you know what i mean there's not many
filmmakers in allentown um
and so but at the same time i'm not you
know going out to cocktail parties or
things to know what's going on
you know down the street right now we're
in la it's like you know what i mean so
it's like
and so i'm so removed and that is a
problem because i i can't rub elbows
with people and
and that's my own problem that's my own
fault it's my own challenge it's a
matter of like i need to
be present more um and i think that um
you know if more people knew what i was
doing and i was more
positioned i guess you would say uh i
could be more successful
um but it just is the nature of the
beast
you said earlier that you know you need
to be more present maybe not being in
l.a hurts you
i'm wondering if there's actually
advantages to you being in allentown
because
you're around like a smaller pool of
people who might be more
supportive not that people aren't
supportive in la but there's so
many projects there's so many people
hitting you up on a daily basis
come see my band come see this so um
well
it's interesting is because um being in
allentown
um i end up doing a lot of teaching of
crew
um a lot of um
handholding and things and so it's
interesting is because now we're in
i'm in la you know promoting my film and
um two people gonna be seeing are people
that work for me
you know here that are very successful
here now you know and because like i
i i teach them by doing i'm not gonna
let them
fail i will take the responsibility if
they fail right
when they're working with me you know
that's how i that's how i manage i'm
going to give you the education i'm
going to give you
the i'm going to empower you to do your
job if you fail that's on me it's not on
you because i didn't instruct you
properly
so i let i give them a lot of free rein
and at the same time i teach them a lot
of different things
like how to read a contract how to do
the whole research that they didn't
learn in film school
but then but then the problem is is it
takes so long for me to produce my next
project that that they have to find
other work
so they come to la and they're
successful so it's interesting it's a
matter of like
um you know so living in in allentown
yeah it's
like i don't have to ask for permission
to do a lot of things
you know i don't need to have like all
these i mean mind you i get all my
locations secured and everything else
but there's not the hassle i think you
have to do in la and new york
um and also people are willing to do
things like we have these crazy
helicopter shots and billboard
because i have a friend that owns a
helicopter so we did these beautiful
aerial shots
you know so it's like yeah we can do
that so i don't know how the hell you do
in new york or here
quite honestly you know you probably
have to do x y and z and jump through
this
this this union and that union like you
know
you know what i mean so it's like it's
like so you know
producing in a town like allentown is
great because of that and it's also
beautiful to shoot it because there's so
many different
varying um scenes and you know scenic
things and everything else
but it has challenges you know that's
the things like people have to realize
when they're shooting on
location you have a lot of location
expenses
can you take us through the sponsorship
process
sure each one was different you said you
had six sponsors
no six revenue streams we have i think
at least
nine spots that's right i'm sorry um
okay so sponsorship is different than
product placement
okay product placement you basically
you know you want to have company x in
your
film um and so you have to clear it
uh to be able to have that that
their ip their trademark their logo in
your in your film
um and so but if you're good at it you
could get a lot of free stuff out of it
i've had i've had directors that i've
worked with in the past like challenged
me like can you get me this can you get
me that and
and generally oftentimes i can get them
crazy stuff
um and um but it's a matter of knowing
how to do it
um and
you have to know what you're asking for
um
and you need to give them a reason why
you're asking for it
and you need to make sure you have your
contracts buttoned up and everything
else as well
now in terms of sponsorship it's a
matter of making sure that they know
that there's going to be an audience for
your project
and so that's one reason why you build
audience early on
and with that being said you have to
make the sponsor as comfortable with the
project as possible
and be very transparent about what
you're doing um
you know brands will not do not like
when you bash their brand obviously
that's not gonna even work i mean we've
even had
um brands say that they have to be their
protagonist not the antagonist
you know and so like it gets to be a
little bit a little bit tricky on
certain things
um but the sponsorship process is you
know creating a deck
um knowing where and how their um
identity's gonna be seen
um what their activations are gonna be
above and beyond just the picture itself
in terms of are there gonna be live
events is it gonna be premieres
is there gonna be you know um you know
anywhere where they could
you know attach themselves to uh you
have to provide these
all this like kind of like packages for
the sponsors
um and so it's work it's a lot of work
to be able to to get it
uh but we were able to raise um
oh gosh uh about 20
of our budget came from sponsorship wow
oh my goodness and how are you choosing
which sponsors to approach
research um and um
what i want i guess you would say like
like literally like
it we're billboard i first went to local
businesses
because we wanted to feel authentic um
and so
it only made sense for us to show off
local businesses
and then after that we green screen the
billboards in the
in the film so we can actually change
out them all if we go to like india we
could change out
the billboards to hindi you know french
the same sort of thing
um and again just think about like an
entrepreneur thinking about
like a business person and um but um
we did that so that the brands could
then see the content
so they would okay it you know what i
mean so so that's kind of like another
reason why too is to try mitigate as
much risk as possible
so you find some brands that you think
would be a good fit and then
you're calling them you're sending an
email
i always call first um and
it's a matter of then it's tracking down
the right person you need to be speaking
to because
every company is different you know some
of them it's a brand manager some of
them is the c
is a cmo some of them is the um
uh they have a sponsor coordinator some
of them
are you know they're movie development
people like for instance some companies
use announce a third party um like i
think it's tier three
and like a bunch of other ones that they
use as a clearinghouse for things so you
then have to talk to them
it's a lot of legwork a lot a lot of
legwork uh but i've been doing it for so
many years that like i
like there's one gentleman uh that was
at lafayette college at a
he was a junior in college and wanted to
intern for me over the summer and i'm
like this is what you're going to be
doing
and he's like how am i going to do that
i'm like i'm going to teach you
i'll tell you what you need to do and he
would come back with me with law
questions all the time and everything
else
and by the end of the summer like you
could be hired by any
major studio because because you're
scrappy
once you've already established who the
brand manager is maybe you've had a
phone call
maybe you've sort of made this like
initial contact you're sending this
is it a pitch deck oh yeah you put a
deck and then you actually even
try and show how their brand is going to
be seen
in the content as well and then you give
them how much time to kind of look at
what's like the
protocol a week a week okay you start
badgering
and then you start negotiating yeah okay
yeah
it everything is so different like um
i could have had some major brands on
our billboards
they didn't want to necessarily give me
money but they would have done it in
trade for a lot of exposure
and i walked away from those deals why
um because i felt like my project had
more value
um and i just
i just i don't know like like um in
retrospect i wish i would have
for a couple or two of them quite
honestly um
but i made the wrong decision
straight up like i don't know what to
say like like and and um
because we could have done some fun
things but at the same time it might
have limited us from other things and
also too was one of them was
um did i want them to be a part of the
project
deep down inside what they're selling
that i really want them a part of it
and so that was that was like kind of
like a gut call that i made
um and um yeah
right right because the thing is that's
going to live on in your film
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you don't feel
right about it right that makes sense
yeah that makes sense i'm not telling
you who it was no no that's okay i'm
always going to ask but
now my mind is going to all different
places wow
so because you have to have integrity
that's the biggest thing it's like it's
like even though you're an entrepreneur
and you think about you know the
business side of
the film business you still have to have
integrity and a vision
you know and that's the thing it's like
you can't sell out uh because if you
um sell out
what are you gonna do next that's such a
you know it's funny because i just
watched this documentary on the clash oh
sure
and so it was like the because joe
strummer passed away it was like 16
years ago or something
and i was looking at all the comments
and you know people were just oh they
sold out and
they became champagne socialist and all
but who wouldn't
want to go to a certain level though
like i i i get
kind of frustrated with the whole
sellout notion and i realize that's a
very indie argument
because there's commercial there's indie
there's the integrity
of of the creativity it's funny because
i don't look at it as selling out i
think it's
um a different way of um
discovering your pain as an artist
because i think that all
artists are trying to overcome some sort
of pain
so that they can be understood i know i
am
so i'm only really speaking for my own
experience but it's like you know you
give the clash as an example
and um i wouldn't say they sold out they
just
figured out a different way to display
their pain
um you know i mean they did have they
did have success
meteoric success mind you um and um
in a form that wasn't even a form yet uh
you know a music forum
and um i mean you could say the sex
pistols before them but
um uh but did they get as much radio
play as the clash did
no no no no no no no no i mean the class
went
international not just out of the uk but
uh but at the same time it's just a
matter of like i just think that you
know
who doesn't like champagne i don't know
what to tell you
social media yeah i'm just i'm just
telling you there's
those videos or someone else's words not
mine yeah mind you i don't think they
sold out but yeah
it was just so fascinating to that that
whole argument so yeah
and i know that especially in certain
genres that's a very touchy thing
is selling out in certain genres whether
it's punk rock or
or certain you know whatever style well
it's funny because like you know growing
up
you know as a punker we had those people
would call posers
oh sure you know those people that that
thought they were and wanted to be but
they weren't true
you know but then also too it's like
it's like it's like it's like i've got
friends that are artists and and
that are actors and musicians and and so
forth that feel like oh well they sold
out
and i'm like what the hell does that
mean that they actually have some sort
of commercial success and you don't and
you're and you're jealous
jealousy is an interesting sort of this
poison arrow into that argument
because i always feel like that's a lot
of times where it comes from yeah
so well it's just like it's just like
you know um
going back to the gatekeeper thing it's
also a matter of like well they got in
and i didn't and so are they jealous of
those people that got in
and they didn't you know it's a matter
of but again it's a matter of like
where are you know programmers at
you know i mean so it's like it's like
it's funny it's because you can talk
about gatekeepers you can talk about
jealousy you can talk about all these
things
but at the end of the day your success
is going to ride on what you do
know what other people do to you um you
have to work your butt off like and and
i always think about like you know every
no is
is one step closer to a yes you know and
and
um you know and you know i've had
moderate success
you know i you know i'm not rolling in
dough by any means
um yes i pay my bills i've got two girls
in college one in high school
um you know so you know we live a family
life
you know and um you know it's not easy i
mean my wife's
also a photographer an amazing
photographer and so we're both freelance
you know and so but we make it work you
know because we work
you know you can't sit back and say
you're a filmmaker and not do the damn
work you just you just
can't you know even when you're when
even when you're prepping for a film
you know i i want to try and see a
producer friend of mine and she's like
you know um she's like right now i'm i'm
i'm a pre-pro on a film you know what
that's like
and she's she's one of the producers on
it and um
and i'm like we'll find the tom even if
i'm walking to set with you or something
like that or you're doing location
scouting because i just want to
catch up because we did his panel out in
out of minneapolis and had a great time
together
and i really respect her work but it's
just a matter of like she is an
accomplished
producer and she is still
working 16 18 hours a day wow
yeah she does she she's doing what it
takes
you know and and i give her so much
profits because of it
so so the notion of the sell-out
it doesn't really exist then
i think this the idea of a sellout is
somebody that's not doing the work
anymore
that they're that they're resting on
their laurels of work they've done in
the past
that's a sellout i think interesting you
know it's not somebody that's
still doing the work and still making
money at it
you know i don't think anybody's gonna
shame anybody for still working hard
but if they start to if they start to
like like you know rest on the laurels
and like
be like you know like flaunting stuff
and everything else you've got the time
and everything else i think that's where
it's going to come down to
so even if someone goes mainstream it's
not a sellout
hell no i'd love to go mainstream yeah i
think billboard deserves to be
mainstream so i really think that
people are going to be very very
affected by the story it's it's
it's about an underdog trying to succeed
in our world that is so media heavy
and how media plays a part in in one's
success or failure
it's a matter of legacy it's a matter of
you know trying to do
something really really hard
you know and it's a matter of um giving
people an opportunity to get ahead
and what they do with that opportunity
is up to their own discretion
you know some people are going to seize
it some people are going to fail at it
you know so it's this whole it's this
whole play on a lot of different
elements and
our film should go mainstream because it
kicked people in the ass and make them
think about it that you know what
sometimes you don't win you shouldn't
get a trophy
for not winning you shouldn't get a
trophy just for participating
your life's hard you're going to win
you're going to lose but you have to
learn how to lose
and in our society today everybody candy
coats everything that you
oh you can't lose you know that's why
they don't keep scoring little league
games that's horse [ __ ]
it really is it's like it's like you
know like i lost a lot
you know i've lost a lot in terms of you
know monetary things i've lost a lot in
terms of i had a lot of friends die
you know that's permanent you know what
i mean but it's just a matter of like i
learned from all that stuff and that's
one reason why i'm grateful that i went
through the stuff that i had to as a kid
that my daughters didn't have to go
through the same sort of thing because i
believe that
you know there's so much universal
negative and so many universal positive
from five got the little more to the
negative
that's great so more people don't have
to deal with it i'm fine with that i
really am and i'm at peace with it
but it's just a matter of like you know
people have to learn how to lose in our
society
and it's just like you know
i don't know girl said i don't know what
to say it's like it's like it's like
there's so much
you know you know there's bullying going
on because they're in f
they feel they have inferior complexes
you know they've got to bully on
somebody else because like
they think that they're better than
somebody else without looking themselves
in the mirror and telling the truth
there's a lot of this stuff going on and
it's a matter of like
billboard hits on a lot of these themes
you know it also hits on the i think
i've taken advantage of people
you know and and it's a matter of like
you know how our society
with a lot of reality tv show stuff and
everything else and and social media
that we've come
you know humans on display like like
are we like literally watching other
human beings almost as like zoo animals
you know taking the you know taking the
the voyeuristic view and not
participating in life
you know it's just like it's there's so
many things that we hit on
that it it's hard to it's hard to say
but it it's
all wrapped around this crazy idea of a
spectacle you know but we don't we don't
deal with the spectacle we deal with the
actual
what goes on behind the spectacle the
web series deals with the spectacle but
the film deals with what goes on behind
the scenes
but i don't even know where i went with
that but it's like it's like you know it
it's making it is what we all strive to
be
and you know you asked about the
american dream earlier as a matter of
like
as long as i can keep doing what i'm
doing i've accomplished the american
dream is because like you know i'm still
being creative you know i'm still
providing i'm still doing all those
sorts of things
you know um do i drive a fancy car to
some probably i do
you know to some i don't you know and
it's just a matter of like but that's
not what's important to me
what's important to me is that you know
my family's provided for that's number
one then number two is i can continue to
be creative that's success to me
you know however i have to go about
doing it i'll i'll do
you know and i'm not afraid to clean
toilets if i have to you know it's all
part of
the the plan for success and you know
you're not you're not above it you know
and also too it's like a lot of people
in the film industry aren't as fortunate
as i've been
um you know that they have you know two
or three different side hustles or stuff
like that but
but you know so do people that are
full-time jobs are still trying to make
rent
you know filmmaking is no different you
know and but it's a craft that's a big
thing that you know the only way to be
better at to be a better filmmaker is to
practice your craft
sometimes it's actually helpful oh yeah
i really do because you become
you you end up being a fighter you know
and and it's funny because like once
you're provoked
um you'll have the like the like you
know you'll get the fuse like it's funny
because i've gotten i
i've turned f using some major successes
um
and because i figure out a way to get
around those gatekeepers um
and it's funny because like i've done
some
pretty i thank god i'm surrounded by by
people that are smarter than me
and and um can i have ideas and they can
basically make those things happen
sometimes
and and it's kind of fun but but you
know sometimes you know
getting your air up and having somebody
not believing you
is just enough to push you over the edge
to make you do something you know
yeah i think we've for some people
they've maybe had a
more coddling and so maybe sometimes
that's harmful
it might be great because then it's like
oh tell us what you've done that's great
but then for others who maybe didn't
have that
i think it pushes you a little bit
harder because if you don't have sort of
this like
cheering squad it might you know it's
funny
is is that you know we're getting you
know some great reviews on billboard and
i'm extremely
grateful for them and you know um
i've had people that are in media as
well as me how i'm doing
you know how's my mental state these
days you know
and i'm like it's interesting it's weird
because like it's easier
for me to deal with negative than it is
for me to deal with positive
uh maybe because i've always had to deal
with a negative and i've always
it's like kind of like the
fight-or-flight kind of mentality um
you know where i've always fought and
said what's happening
um and it's funny because like um i
still feel i can be
better you know and that's the thing
it's like you know maybe it's my own
insecurity or something along those
lines but it's a matter of
of um you know when even in success
i think you can still be better at what
you're doing and you still need to learn
from it
you know you can't say that that euro
scorsese or spielberg don't doesn't look
at a piece of work that they've done
that they've made millions if not
hundreds of millions on
and be like oh that could have been
better or
yeah that could you know or that could
have been better you know you know
anybody worth their you know
weight is going to always evaluate their
work and and
figure out where they can be better
is jeep one of your sponsors yes okay um
how many sponsors had you already
approached before you approached jeep
and
oh geez a lot although jeep was one of
the the ones that i wanted i
i love jeep um i
you all i refinanced a jeep to actually
you know it was interesting because it's
an interesting story to tell
jeep that's how i think we secure them
quite honestly it's a matter of like
you know jeep's been ingrained in my
life since i've been able to drive
you know my first jeep was a cj7 with a
401 in it the three speed you know dual
exhaust like it was a beautiful
old jeep that we refurbished uh then i
ended up getting one
um uh i needed to get to my brother's
wedding
and i went through a bad breakup and
gave her everything
that i owned at that time and moved on
so i had to get to my brother's wedding
so i bought a jeep with cash
and that was a jabra refinance um to
start my
film company um and um
so i had a story to tell jeep and you
know my wife drives a jeep now
um and things so it's just like so like
it's been built into into my dna in fact
there's even
like a little blue jeep uh toy that's
actually part of our set pieces in the
film as well which is kind of funny too
so so there was an emotional meaning too
that they probably picked up on
oh yeah yeah yeah just me it's funny you
could say it but then it's been reported
in media over the course of my career
and and thank god that we do save a lot
of the press clippings and stuff so we
can actually show them that like yeah
look at me in on you know in strip
magazine from one of my films
me sitting on my black jeep that i
refinanced you know what i mean so it's
like so like
you can't just be asked your way through
this stuff you actually have to to prove
it
what do you think most filmmakers get
wrong with their first movie
let's say it's not jeez i don't know
um i can only speak from my own
experience
um
what most filmmakers do wrong with their
first movie
um i don't know i don't know if they do
anything wrong because it's a learning
experience
what they would do wrong was not to make
another one
you know it's like it's like it's like i
can't fault anybody
for i can't i can't pick out one thing
that people do wrong
um some stupid things that people do
that i know of is like they don't clear
things
so they can't sell it you know that just
is that's just
you know a dumb move um
um but i gotta say like every film that
one does
is an experience to make a better one in
the future
you know so i can't say that like you
know a first film is is something
negative like i know what i did wrong
you know and everything else and i
learned from it and
you know my next one was better than the
next film that was better and like i
keep you know getting better
over time you know um but um
yeah i don't know i don't know if
there's one thing that i would say that
most people get wrong
but i like that then not by not making a
second that's true yeah it's like it's
like because if you make
you know even if your first film doesn't
make any money and you owe
you know 30 000 in credit card debt or
something like that
you know paying off that debt and then
doing your next pictures you're probably
your biggest disservice to yourself
uh because you then can actually make a
better film based off of those things
you learn from your first one
you know um yeah i that's the biggest
thing it's like
yeah i think in another interview you
said you you run a tight ship
on set oh i do it's great yeah what are
five things the director needs to do
when they first get on set
okay so are you referring to just the
as a director or you're talking about a
director producer
let's try a director producer okay
because that's what i do
um i've never had the luxury of just
being a director that's why i have to
ask that question because being a
producer you're worried about money from
day one
um so what i do
is i make sure that everybody's on time
i'm i am very um i'm extremely tough
about that i
fired people because they arrive late um
straight up
just because you know you have a key
that is late and you have
10 people standing around even if
they're 15 minutes late
10 people times 15 you know is basically
an hour and two and a half hours
of time people you've lost when you're
dealing with miniscule budgets
that kind of stuff adds up very quickly
and that means money lost
so i take that stuff extremely seriously
i rehearse my actors i know what i want
i don't vacillate on set
i know what i need to cover because i'm
thinking about the edit
i shoot for the edit and then i give
some freedom
i'm very much a stickler upon my script
uh very much so i don't really allow
much improv um
because again it comes down to budget
you know with the web series we let a
lot of improv go because we had a
different budget structure for that than
we did
for the feature film um but um
that uh the one thing that i do too is i
try and make breakfast for everybody
uh just because um one is it puts me in
the mindset of what i need to do for the
day just by the repetition of doing
things
also too as a matter of welcoming people
to the set that day
and then also the idea of uh if you go
into
later hours people are generally a
little bit more friendlier because i
know you fed them
i know it sounds crazy that's not why i
do but i've learned that that's that's
the benefit of it
um and um it's just something that like
you know
in my early career i worked in the f b
business while i was in
making films and stuff which i strongly
suggest anybody doing
i think somebody that works in the
restaurant business
is a great proving ground for great
filmmakers especially producers just
because you have to think about a lot of
different things
and i get into that a whole other topic
but um
uh i make sure everything's buttoned up
but make sure that we have call sheets i
make sure that
everybody that i have a shot list for
everybody um i'm just i'm
very organized in fact it's funny
because my wife always says like
i wish you ran the rest of your life
like you're running your productions
you know because everything would have
its place everything's very specific
um you know and it's not to say that
that that like you know my
my my sets are um dismal to be on that's
not what i'm saying at
all but i just need that that
you know uniformity so that we can
rest you know so i know that
everything's being taken care of because
when you're producing and directing
you know you're doing a lot of internal
battles in your head because like you
know like [ __ ] i didn't get that shot
i need to take it again but then you're
losing light and then you realize that
oh my gosh i gotta light this thing
it's gonna we're gonna we're gonna run
over overtime and so now all of a sudden
like
i'm doing the math in my head and be
like oh wow like is it worth it
you know and so you have these little
battles in your head if you're a
director producer
um you know i always like also make sure
i surround myself with like you know a
go-getter like
you know uh ryan is just he's a beast
he just dug in early on and just got
stuff done for me
um assumed a lot of responsibility um
you know and my entire team it's a
matter of everybody understanding what
the vision is
and and getting everybody to follow that
vision uh
my dp matt um you know it just it just
it's interesting
um you know every every film
set has their own battle scars um
and big question is would you go to
battle again with those people
that's the biggest question you have to
ask after a shoot um
and i've gone to battle with people many
times
so well how is working in a restaurant
preparing you
for a film set oh so many things
um so
as a waitron um you think fast on your
feet
you also have to realize that you know
you're constantly pleasing people
you have to remember a lot of things um
you know what you carry out of the
kitchen you should be carrying something
back so it's a matter of efficiency
uh if you're really good to the if you
work your butt off and you're good to
the owner the owner might even cater
your
your film shoot um you know you get uh
generally a meal a day
as well so that means that you only have
to provide yourself two meals
um you know there's the idea of
camaraderie in a matter of like you know
getting through something that's very
hectic uh because most restaurants are
very hectic at least at some point of
of a shift it's a matter of
working in your feet for long hours
and you also have to stay very organized
as well in terms of of regimenting in
your head of what has to come next
there's a lot of things working in the
restaurant business it's funny because
like i always tell everybody
the other thing true matter of like
working the restaurant business like you
can do your film business stuff during
the day and then work at night
which is which is what i did earlier on
in my career and then what i would end
up doing is take off for
you know six weeks to shoot my film
you know they always would take me back
so i was a hard worker and things but um
you know that's kind of like how i got
through my early career
any advice on screenwriting books like
what's the best screenwriting book
you've read
i think sid fields is still probably the
bible that's the first one i ever read
um i write every day so to this day
i find writing probably um
i find writing very enjoyable although
it's hilacious at the same time
um because i know that's the only part
of the process that i know is solely me
everything else is is pretty much
collaborative you know
and it's give and take uh when you're
writing you don't have to give or take
generally you know
i also take a long time well it's funny
i will think about a script
for at least a year or two before i ever
commit anything to paper
because what i do first is i know the
story that i want to tell and then i
build out the characters and then i want
to know
i have to build up the characters so
well that
they can then end up just talking to
each other and then i can literally
vomit out a script in days generally how
it works for me and then i do rewrites
from there
um but also too is i only will create
characters that want to
play as an actor um
you know uh i find that you know like my
next project is gonna be
a challenge for my two leads in a big
way and and um
uh yeah
um and um but that's kind of like why
like i love writing
um and the thing is too it's like with
writing uh it's all in the rewrite and
the biggest thing with writing too
is like i like to share uh what i what
i'm writing with people
uh and get their honest feedback i don't
do it the people are gonna be yes
you know say like oh this is great like
i literally want real criticism
and also too is getting back to the
whole entrepreneur spirit and this stuff
is i'm so bold
that i will hold live script readings of
my
scripts for audience feedback the
audience literally pays to go
i pay the actors i generally make money
on my scripts readings
and but at the same time it's very
valuable
because then i hear what's working
what's not working and also too is get
the audience feedback
again all part of this whole story r d
that i've been very much involved in
uh and how i create um and i actually i
have like four stages of that i find
that you need to create to be successful
and this doesn't just go for film but it
also goes for
if you're a musician or an artist you
have a dance company or whatever
and so it's a matter of something that
i've been perfecting over the course of
billboard
um and it's it's funny because you
mentioned the whole
um no film school it's like literally
what i wrote into a film school the four
stages of of create for
creative success uh and i blogged about
it and everything else as well
um but writing is is the
um most crucial part of this whole thing
and if something's not working on set
it's also true it's important that you
actually sit down and and kind of
rewrite and make sure that
that it will work i mean mind you as i
said before with billboard
is that when we got into post it didn't
some elements just didn't work
um and so i had to rewrite and and
billboards very is a very very complex
script to write
because not only did i have to worry
about the feature film but i also had to
worry about how it fit into the web
series
so if i would change one thing in the
film i had to make sure it worked for
the web series this was very very
complex and also too is like how we're
playing with media
is that some some shots we shot we
actually had to do
three different iterations of that scene
to get the entire scene
for instance like you know we would have
a news
cast a newscaster
speaking on tv but on the screen and the
newscast was part of the billboard
contest and then
that screen ended up being in another
shot
so you understand so like just what you
had to go through to try and make this
whole thing happen that was a big a big
challenge with uh with the script
literally having to like realize that
one scene sometimes took
you know three different pieces of
three different layers i should say to
make the the scene cohesive
right well you said that you you think
about the idea for
a film for maybe one or two years and
then
basically you vomit out the first draft
because you feel like you know the story
and the character so well
do you give that draft some time before
you go in for the rewrites
or do you no i actually i do i generally
give it a
week or two and then i'll reread it and
then from right there is when i start to
make
notes it's funny because when i um when
people ask me to read scripts
i break out a pen and um
and i will literally start i i just i
don't know why but i literally if it's
formatting issue or anything like that
and quite honestly if like things are
not right in the first 10 pages i i
won't carry on
oh you won't no not even if i'm engaged
i'm like rewrite it it's it's it
you know your formatting is off this x y
and z and everything else
you know there's too many spelling
mistakes i mean it's crazy it's like
it's like it's like i know it sounds
horrible
but if you're gonna if you're gonna ask
me
to take my time to read something make
sure it's readable
you know and it's it's important it's
not just just respectfully it's
important i think
you know i've had people that like oh
i've got this great script you know they
gave me a tag
line okay sure i'll read it and then
it's not even script format
it's like what the hell are you doing
you know like like i can't even read
this
and people don't understand either is
because screenwriting there is a formula
for it because
you know as a producer now like i know
that a page is going to basically be a
minute of screen time if it's a very
black page it's going to be more than
one minute you know black page meaning a
lot of action that's
spelled out in the script and so um
uh so i started thinking about budget i
start thinking about all these sorts of
things when i'm reading a script but
whether
i could produce it or what i would need
to do to be able to make it happen
um and so my i'm always reading
something as a producer
first before i read it i guess that's
why i'm probably reading so many scripts
i wanted to produce it
my own scripts though is i'm pretty i'm
very tough on myself
and um like i just write and rewrite and
write and rewrite and write and rewrite
how do you know when it's done
it's not done until i'm editing the
picture
quite honestly yeah because because like
because you know you still edit things
in
in you know you still edit things so
you're constantly editing
you're on location you're editing
generally because you might not you know
use a certain line or something like
that so it's funny it's like it's like
um or somebody says something wrong and
then you all of a sudden have to adapt
something to change it so
the script is still like yes you have to
lock in the script to be able to
schedule everything to you know
have your you know your your production
plans and so forth
but at the same time like the script's
really not locked until post-production
how do you know when a transmedia
project is finished
when it all works because it's very it's
very
um like oh gosh
overall script for billboard is 410
pages
oh wow um and if i would have
if somebody would have handed me that as
a producer i would have said you're out
of your
mind um
really out of your mind um and so like i
just had to make sure
like so i actually challenged some some
students from lafayette
uh to do um some writing uh for it
and then i ended up having to do a bunch
of rewriting because of it just didn't
some things didn't work
um and just i just had to do it and so
uh but the script ended up being 410
pages long
um and um because the web series is just
it's
you know over three hours if you put all
the content together
can we hear more about the process of
writing the script and also how are you
writing it and then writing the web
series or you're not writing it at the
same time
sure so um i write them independently at
first i generally will start with the
feature script
because still on still the the feature
film is still
paramount in this whole creative process
um it has to you have to have something
to hang everything on it's like what i
call the main event
um and so the web series um
is secondary to that and but it has to
be able to fit into
this to the film script what i mean by
that is like certain story elements have
to be parallel
um i then have um holders what i call
them
that there might be a scene the same
scene in the web series that's also in
the film
told from a different perspective so
that the audience
knows that this is the storyline
um you know and so it sounds very
complex and so what you need to do is
just
you start to map it out and what i'll do
is i will print out
each scene by scene and what i'll do is
i will tab out
the scene so it's a white page then and
keep everything very
you know um very separate and then what
i'll do then is on a different color
paper
i will then print out the web series and
and coral and
collate them together and then read them
all
one one continuous story to make sure
that everything makes sense then i'll
start making edits from that
so again what i do is i will i will you
know chat out each scene
um you know have it all individually and
then i'll color code
with the web series uh so that i can
make sure that it's one cohesive story i
don't know if that makes sense does that
make sense to you
somewhat so with the 410 pages
how is that if i'm reading it is that
like is part of it in the middle
then we stopping for the web series or
i'm just curious
no it can actually read as one long
script
yes so i don't really so i know which is
which
uh by the by the color of paper and also
just by being the author of it too i
know which is which
uh but it should be able to read as one
cohesive story
um you know when you're if you're
shutting down to read all 410 pages
and so when you're saying a main event
and now it's taking
place in the web series from another
perspective it just all flows because
now you know it's somebody else's
experience with that same
event yes like for instance um
the center of the billboard right so the
the the characters go up on the
billboard in both
the web series and also in the film but
then once they get up to the billboard
it's different right the radio station
has what they have to deal with
and the billboard centers have to deal
with what they have to deal with
and so that's like literally what i
would call a holder so that's like the
literally the start of the web series
and then part of the film you know then
what might what
might be happening like something
happens up in the billboard you know the
radio station
um jocks uh react
and then you see what is actually going
on the billboard so it's like that's how
it all works out it's a cause and effect
kind of play
right okay so when you would make a
change
to the main part of the story um
take us through through the process of
then going back in and and
is it just you know at this moment in
the web series is a similar moment in
the script
and so just to go in and modify it yeah
and also too
it has to be something that is also
provocative as well
you know what i mean like you can't have
um
[Music]
something that doesn't provoke that
change
and what i mean by that is a matter of
um
if you change something in one you might
have to change something in the other
again because a lot of it's cause and
effect it's it's two different points of
view of the same story
um but then the challenge comes in
then you shoot all this stuff and then
you're in the editing room and you want
to make a change
so then not only do you have to worry
about changing the film that it makes
sense
now you have to change the web series to
make sure it makes sense and that
everything actually works together it's
extremely complex
very very complex and so there's a lot
of organization that takes place there's
a lot of work that takes place and
everybody has to be on the same page
and everybody really really needs to pay
hyper attention and continuity
um because without good continuity like
this stuff will fall apart very fast
it becomes a mess you know and and the
reason that i feel that what we're doing
works is because we paid so much
attention to that
so you're releasing the web series
you've already released it all the
sections before the actual feature film
has come out we did yeah and so what's
funny is because people see the film
want to see the web series generally
that's generally how it's been happening
uh and so the people have been
downloading the web series then go to
billboardmovie.com
uh and then it's up on vimeo right now
it will
the web series will be released on other
digital platforms
but we chose that first because there
was a paywall there because obviously we
need to make money
um and because this content has just
cost us a lot of
freaking money um and um also we
went that model instead of the youtube
model uh just because
of um we wanted people to
buy into the story world not just
watch content yeah it's two different
ways of looking at things two different
mindsets you're going to to
view content then interesting so if it
was just
if you had all the parts of the web
series uploaded for free
on youtube where there was no paywall
for it you felt that people wouldn't be
as engaged
it just was content then i feel you know
just
more more noise out there like we do
have we do have short
aspects of the web series up on youtube
but it's pretty much for promotional
purposes
uh for the for the longer um episodes um
but it's just a matter of like one of
those decisions i had to make is like
where i wanted this to be to live and
to be seen um and so it lives on vimeo
as is the portal that we're choosing for
right now will you put the feature film
um with a paywall online for people yeah
not right now because we're in theaters
um but we will
yeah well it's gonna be you know it's
gonna end up on itunes
uh amazon roku ad rise like all these
other portals and stuff
uh just not in the us but
internationally as well
so with your tour are you going overseas
at all
i hope so um it's funny because in
search of did better overseas than it
did in the united states
uh i have more of a of a um european
sensibility to filmmaking i guess i i
didn't know that i
it's not my intention it just ends up
being that way
um because um i guess like
you know i'm okay with things not being
wrapped up in a pretty bow
um and uh i'm more of a very authentic
storyteller
uh and i don't mind the rawness of
things um and so like for instance
within search of there was a lot of
nudity in it
um and um uh you know our britannic
society has a hard time with seeing
penises and breasts
i don't get it i really don't or you
know they find it titillating which i
think is a crack of [ __ ]
um and um you know so in europe it's not
a big deal
uh and so um you know i'm constantly
pushing the boundaries on things um
and storytelling i mean we got an r
rating so it wasn't you know
sex or anything like that it's just a
matter of like the human body
just kind of weird did you tone down
any nudity or i don't know how much
nudity is in billboard but there's no
dude
oh no i can't i can't say that there is
a bit of newly in billboard but it
wasn't
it was pg 13. that was not me okay yeah
yeah but no it's just like as as i was
saying it's a matter of um
within search of i found that my
sensibility of filmmaking is geared
very european um and um
the billboard is kind of i think pretty
much the same way although it's an
american story so it's gonna be
interesting how that plays out
internationally
i think you said that you had a
difficult time securing
with in search of some of the male
full-frontal that some people didn't
wouldn't even show it did i hear that
right or where did you hear that
i said it i've said it it's true you
said it in a video yep i did okay
uh i just want to make sure that i know
where what you're referring to
so um it's interesting that um
in our wonderful society that you can
show any part of the female anatomy
uh and it'll clear various portal
sensors
itunes show any sort of
male genitalia on itunes they will ask
you to cut it
which i think is completely wrong um you
know and i think it's sexist
i think it is one of those things that
society has to change because i just
don't think that
and the reason that there's a lot of
nudity in in search of because you can't
be talking about sex and sort of things
without there being nudity
um and uh it's not a matter of it's not
in any way gratuitous um and there's
both male and female
nudity in it like i'm like you know like
unbiased with it
um and it's just one of those things
that i think is is is
is nonsense it's it's a matter of like i
think that
you know if you're going to do one then
you know you should have the other
um and you know they did the same
without a tenant by lieutenant you know
they cut the uh the
harvard cartels on that too on itunes
was that when he was in the car
i'm trying to think of that he came
after somebody i forget the exact scene
but
but um it's been referenced a couple of
times and and my
my aggregator referenced it and then
showed me the before and after eclipse
and was like that's
that's nonsense but interesting you
think it well
this is a touchy well no pun intended do
you
think that makes men uncomfortable that
are quote unquote straight
to see i and i we're really gonna prank
it no i
i'm i'm i'm um i uh
do you think that i don't know the
problem with it the weird thing about it
is
men will be in locker rooms you have all
these guys that are jocks
and they're naked amongst one another
right and then all of a sudden they see
male genitalia on
in in a film like ah it doesn't make any
sense to me
you know what i mean and so and so like
i played sports all my life i've i've
i have a panache for streaking for that
matter i think it's kind of fun um
so that kind of like lets you know like
kind of like how i'm about the whole
damn thing
was that you with the emmys
uh but um uh but no it's just a matter
of like i think
i don't know why men are uncomfortable
by it
you'll find these beautiful works of art
like for instance david you know
in florence um you know obviously
completely naked you know and it's
considered a work of art the same thing
with you know even the female anatomy as
well
um but i think that um there's no reason
why
male anatomy has to be shunned i don't i
don't get it
it's not like you see
the form of body i think is attractive
regardless if
it's male or female um it's not to say
that i'm attracted
to i find it attractive two different
ways of looking at this
so if you look at at body as a form of
art in a matter of
expression um it's one thing
once you uh objectify it's completely
different
and that's the things like within our
culture is like so many people objectify
you know body and a body is a vessel
for our mind and our spirit that's what
it freaking is
you know and and you know yes some are
attractive some are not
um just like some art is attractive and
some art is not and it's just a matter
of like i think that
you know um you know people with
inferiority complexes are going to shun
away from
male genitalia quite honestly and i
think i think you know
that's your own insecurity it's it's
that's all i can say
you know so i've seen women get
uncomfortable
sometimes but i think there's various
reasons for that you mean with other
women comfortable
seeing other females yeah yeah i've seen
that and i think i could
go to different things it could go to
maybe if they have a daughter
and they feel uncomfortable with a young
woman showing themselves because they
envision their daughter
and they would like well i wouldn't want
her to do that or there's a jealousy
factor and some women have a spectrum
of the jealousy factor some women are on
the very very end of it which is
they're not they don't really care and
others are on the you know
red light and it's they're just totally
pissed off and then i think
it's considered too provocative
and women get fearful because they don't
want to face their own
issues around that well it's interesting
with nudity today though
is a matter of like with the whole me
too movement you're going to see
probably less nudity in films
and i think that
if it's not gratuitous and it's not
gender biased i think that it should be
fine
um that's the thing it's a matter of
like it all comes down to the bias
um you know and the thing is like it's
like you know when we were on the set up
in search of like you know it was you
know close set whenever there was nudity
uh complete respect for it and
everything else um and you know there
was both male and female alike and
that's the thing it's like it's like you
know
um and i don't know like i just look at
it differently like i'm not i'm not
intimidated i guess
you know and that's what it comes down
to um
and um you know and at the same time
like i expressed to my daughters the
same sort of thing
um you know that it's a matter of like
you know your body is your own and and
and that's sort and and you have to do
what you're comfortable with um
and even you know with you know my next
feature there is nudity in it as well
um but it's not you know it's unbiased
you know i just because it has to be and
there's a point to it it's not
it's not it's not because you know i
just want to see tna i mean
you know it's not that it it's not that
at all it's a matter of expression it's
a matter of vulnerability when you see
nudity in a film and you're telling a
story
i think it should be really about
showing the vulnerability of somebody
not necessarily
you know the size of somebody's breasts
it just doesn't make any sense
you know what i mean like like like i
don't know
i hear you yeah um what why do you think
inferiority
stops people from wanting nudity in in
films
well i mean you know because they're not
secure in their own sexuality
or or what their wares are i should say
i think you know like you know some
people like um you know
have an inferiority complex it's a
matter of like well like you know i'm as
endowed as that person or he's more
doubt than i am that kind of stuff or
even even with like female like you know
the whole body shaming stuff and
everything else that happens
it's the same sort of idea that's what i
mean by very complex it's a matter of
like the idea of
they have something that i don't have or
that i wish i had and so they just
rather shut it down
advice for somebody planning a first
time transmedia project
wow uh advice on somebody wanting to do
a transmedia project
um one is you really need to flesh out
what your objective is
uh because something just to do it
because it's a fad or something just
because it's cool
is the wrong reasons to do it you have
to realize it has to be built into the
story's dna
you also have to have a reason for why
you're doing what you're doing
uh anything that does not meet that
objective is just marketing
um you know so the big thing with
transmedia
is trying to tell a different facet of a
story
in a different way generally on a
different media
um different medium i should say um and
so it's the idea of
um wanting to do that
and not necessarily and also needing to
do it to a point
like with billboard that i wanted to
create two different sides of the same
story one from the radio's perspective
one from
the billboard sort of perspective cause
and effect one thing does one thing
it affects the other and vice versa um
that's probably the easiest way to do it
um when you're dealing a lot with um you
know like i've got friends
in that produced in transmedia space and
they do things very tech heavy um
my big thing is is to not create the
least amount of friction as possible for
your audience
meaning don't have to jump through hoops
to be able to be entertained by what
you're creating
make sure that it's accessible um
just to wow your audience is not enough
i mean you know ar became a big thing
with pokemon now
uh and everybody then wanted to do
something with ar in the transmedia
space but to me
it's like the only reason to do
something like that is if
it's authentic to your story um
because also too is people only get
deeper into a story
if they feel it's authentic that they
want to follow the story
so that's a big thing too is like making
sure that you have um
the proper amount of interest of what
you're doing
you know that appeals to the widest
enough audience as well
um you know we're still like working on
fighting audience for billboard um
you know and it's growing thank god um
and
producing transmedia is is hard it's
also gonna cost a lot more money it's
gonna take a lot more time
straight up uh because it has to because
it's creating more media
you know and creating more things you
have to understand how you're gonna
market
all these things as well because i got
to tell you i've spent the last 10 years
educating
uh that's one reason i think too it's
taken me so long to get billboard out
there as well it's like i still speak
on colleges all the time you know about
transmedia
and no matter like what this stuff is
and and um
i just don't like the word transmedia i
i call it a cine experience
because we create live events it's a
whole it's a whole experience it's not
just
media you know it's an experience in my
mind and so it's it's it's not only
um it's for the creative and also the
user
and everybody's going to have to say a
different experience of how they attack
uh the content what's the
what are some of the most prevalent
questions you get when you go to the
colleges
why why why do i do this why not just
make a movie
um and it's funny because my wife asked
me that same question would you just
stop doing this and just
do a film it's so much easier and i
can't because that's not how i create
you know what i mean like like when i
when i we did um in search of
um you know i go on college campuses and
like you know indiana university
wouldn't even let a show
um in search of on their campus and you
have to realize indiana university has a
kinsey institute which is
like the such education institute in the
united states and
insurgent was even too provocative for
them and there's no sex in it doesn't
make anybody sense
at all you know so the funny the reason
i'm saying that is like because then we
did all these different things on
college campuses with with um
in search of and i created um um
uh experiences where the audience would
watch the film and then they would share
story
um and um and the funny thing is is like
the religious right have actually really
attached themselves to the film uh which
is very interesting even though there's
a lot of nudity in it
um and i find that very fascinating and
so like even with in search of there was
that
extra element of storytelling that we
did um you know sponsored by a condom
company all these sorts of things
we were actually you know teaching about
safe sex and things
uh but then also then with so like i've
been doing this is built into how i
create
you know um you know with aka i built
out
installations um of this the character's
apartment and things
um and then had his band perform live in
places
um and then with it with with billboard
it's just a matter of you know by
creating this crazy radio station
enables me to do all kinds of fun stuff
you know and
uh where people literally can go in and
experience part of the story
um in a different way and it has to be
authentic that's the biggest thing
you just can't do it just to do it it
has to be really authentic
uh and even my next film my next film is
about is a love story
um and you know it still has trans
media elements to it because the lead
female
is a ballerina and i wrote the ballet
that's in the film that i actually want
to mount aside from
the actual film so the ballet will
actually be toured
separate from the film and then you know
the lead
the lead characters child i've got an
attorney that's also a writer and he has
a book of poetry that
you know um i've been writing and things
too so
there's all these different types of
things that we end up telling the story
through
but it's it's how i create i don't i
don't know any different
and so it's like literally been built in
my dna and that's one reason why i
create the way i do
when is billboard finished well the
creation of
billboard is finished um you know right
now we're
in theatrical release and what we're
doing with the film is we're kind of
like taking it to a market to market
saturation
uh so we're literally screening the film
in different markets around the around
the country
uh then it'll go to on the digital
platforms and and that sort of thing uh
we also
are still hosting live events with the
different bands
uh from from uh the radio station um and
we're creating events around that
um and the web series is currently in
release you know
there's still bands that are submitting
music to wtyt uh so i don't know
i don't know if it will ever be done
because i guess it'll be done when i
probably turn
off the radio station maybe just because
like this thing's kind of like created
a life of its own um and that's the
weird interesting thing about about
creating in this space like you know and
it's a matter of like i created
something
that i gave over to the audience and
they're doing whatever the heck they
want with it
you know and as a creator that's a
little scary because generally you're a
little bit control freaks
um but it's interesting that like bands
are still
finding it they're still uploading their
music and we're still sharing it with
people
that's that's a cool and very powerful
thing um
so in a way it's still growing it's like
the blob
you know it's still out there still
getting bigger and we're still trying to
find you know
like an audience for everything you know
and and we're determined
we we firmly believe we have a really
quality film in our hands
uh that's gonna speak to a lot of people
and so we're gonna take our time with it
you know we don't want to just like you
know be a flash in the pan and be gone
we want it to
you know to grow legs um you know and
you know i think it's gonna be some time
yet and we're excited to share
so then the audience sort of the owns
your movie in a sense
they're the sort of the it's not yours
anymore you know the
saying no no it's it's what they it's
how they take it
it's interesting like when we opened
this past weekend
um we had decent numbers um and we did
we were we're being held over in all the
independent houses
um the ones that we were in multiplexes
were not being held over which kind of
tells us something about the sensibility
of cinema
but at the same time um our audiences
are growing
which is kind of cool um you know so
that just bro
more people were at the theaters on
monday
than they were on sunday and it's kind
of interesting that that it's kind of
like growing which is
which is an interesting barometer you
know so obviously word of mouth is
happening and so it's going to be
interesting to see
you know when we get final box office
results at the end of the week where
that all comes in from
are you ready for your next transmedia
project am i ready
i've already i i don't know if you're
ever ready
it just as a it's just a part of me it's
how i create
you know um and um i'm gonna be working
with i think some other people about
uh producing their own work just because
i i
done this i've done you know the first
transmedia project at sundance with
lance
wheeler pandemic and that was a big
challenge but we learned a lot from that
experience
and you know i worked with lance and
david kronenberg at his installations
that are
going around to museums around the world
uh so i do produce other people's
work uh i've been very head down working
on billboard
for so many years that i actually would
love to work on other people's projects
um and um because
again like this is just second nature to
me i don't i don't know how else to
create
um and and i've got some amazing
talented people that have
worked with me on this stuff that i
think would
enjoy working on something new